GOOD MORNING EVERYONE WELCOME TO
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE THREE ON
THIS VERY BEAUTIFUL APRIL TWENTY
SEVENTH SACRAMENTO DAY-
APOLOGIZE FOR THE NOISE OUTSIDE.
BUT- IT IS WHAT IT IS WE'RE
UNDER CONSTRUCTION NEAR. OR AT
LEAST UNDER DEMOLITION WE'RE
HAVING AN IN PERSON HEARING
TODAY AND CAPITOL ROOM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN THE PANELISTS
LISTED IN THE AGENDA WILL BE
APPEARING IN PERSON. THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY PERSON MAY DO
SO WHEN I OPENED THE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING. AFTER THOSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM OF SPOKEN WE WILL
ALLOW PHONE TESTIMONY. THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE
ALSO ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET.
PHONE NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957
THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AND YOU'LL NEED AN ACCESS CODE
THAT'S 1-315-127-1315 ONE TWO
SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
pCONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE. AT. 916-319-2099 AND
A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU.
ALL COMMENTERS WILL HAVE- AS IS
THE CASE IN EVERYONE OF OUR
HEARINGS UP TO ONE MINUTE TO
SPEAK. WE WILL NOT BE TAKING ANY
VOTES TODAY FOR THOSE OF YOU ARE
EXPECTING VOTE SOME SORRY TO
DISAPPOINT YOU- BUT WE DON'T
HAVE A ANY VOTES ON THE NON
PRESENTATION CALENDAR- OR- THE-
DISCUSSION ITEMS TODAY- WE HAVE
FOUR DISCUSSION ITEMS THIS
MORNING FIRST WE WILL THAT ALL
THE PANELISTS GIVE THEIR
TESTIMONY AND THEN OPEN IT UP
QUESTIONS FOR MARK COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AFTER THE DISCUSSION
ITEMS COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY ASK
QUESTIONS OR MAKE COMMENTS ABOUT
THE NON DISCUSSION ITEMS. AND WE
WILL AND WITH PUBLIC COMMENT.
WILL BEGIN NOW WITH ISSUE NUMBER
ONE WILL BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
BECAUSE AS YOU CAN SEE WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET. ISSUE NUMBER
MAKING THE PRESENTATION IF I'M
NOT MISTAKEN. GOOD MORNING. MORE
IN THE GREAT. IT'S THE NEW NEW
NORMAL OF. THE. WELL IT IS.
THERE ARE STILL BE. IN ORDER FOR
A LITTLE. HELLO FINALLY PALOMA
OF THE CLOSE. STELLAR IS THAT
BETTER CAN CAN YOU ALL HER IN
THE BACK OF THE ROOM OKAY THIS-
THIS. NO OUTSIDE THE WIND IS
GOOD ME CRAZY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ABOUT. OR REQUIREMENTS LETTER TO
. DAHLE UNIVERSITE FUN TO
VISIBILITY GREATER ACCESS
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALLING. OTHER
AREAS HERE. AS MANY OF YOU BEEN
A OF THESE OVER MANY DECADES-
THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM IS FUNDAMENTAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S BOTH PERCEPTION AND
REALITY OF RECYCLING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIANS RECYCLED
NINETEEN BILLION- BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS THROUGH THIS PROGRAM
WHICH IS REALLY QUITE- QUITE
REMARKABLE MORE THAN WE'VE EVER
RECYCLE BEFORE. BUT DESPITE THE
FACT THAT WE ARE RECYCLING IN
RECORD NUMBERS OF EBBERS
CONTAINERS WE ARE STILL-
HOVERING AROUND THE SEVENTY PER
CENT RATE OF RECYCLING OF THOSE
PURCHASED AT THE ADMINISTRATION
FEELS AGAIN THAT THIS IS ONE OF
OUR FUNDAMENTAL RECYCLING
PROGRAMS AND THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO ENSURE THAT EVERY CALIFORNIAN
HAS ACCESS TO THIS PROGRAM AND
AN OPPORTUNITY TO. REAP DEEP-
REDEEM THEIR BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
AND- RECEIVED THEIR DEPOSIT BACK
AND SO THIS PROPOSAL- HAS A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT COMPONENTS
TO IT THAT ARE REALLY MEANT TO
ONE INCREASE ACCESS TO THE
OVERALL PROGRAM. AND INCREASING
OPPORTUNITY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ESPECIALLY IN OUR RECYCLING.
THROUGH A NUMBER OF CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS WE'VE BEEN TESTING
ACROSS THE STATE AND THAT WE'VE
SEEN WORK INOTHER STATES. AND
THEN ALSO WE FEEL IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE INVESTMENTS
IN- THE QUALITY INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS- THAT ACTUALLY INCREASE
THE OVERALL QUALITY OF
RECYCLABLE MATERIALS THAT COME
FROM THIS PROGRAM SO THAT WE ARE
INSURING- CONTAINER TO CONTAINER
RECYCLING IN A TROOP CIRCULAR
ECONOMY. WITH THAT. STOP AND I
UP TO ANY OR IF YOU'D LIKE ME TO
GO INTO FURTHER DETAIL AND HAPPY
TO DO THAT AS WELL WELL- FIRST
LET'S HEAR FROM- THE L. A. O.
AND OTHER THAN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN BIRSE ROSS BROWN AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
FIRST OFF I WANT TO SAY THAT WE-
DO THINK GIVEN RECENT DECLINES
IN RECYCLING RATES. AND ISSUES
WITH CONSUMER ACCESS TO ROUTE TO
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES. AND A
SUBSTANTIAL FUND BALANCE IN THE
BCRF WE DO THINK THAT PROVIDING
SOME ONE TIME FUNDING TO IMPROVE
PROGRAM OUTCOMES DOES HAVE
MERIT. HOWEVER WE THINK THIS
SPECIFIC PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS
DOES LACK SOME KEY DETAILS AND
RAISES SOME IMPORTANT. POLICY
QUESTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER. AND PERHAPS ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION AS PART OF THIS.
IS PART OF ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
I'M GONNA RUN. SOME OF THE- IN
QUESTIONS WE THINK GOING FORWARD
SO FIRST IS. DOES THE PROPOSAL
AND DO THE DIFFERENT PIECES OF
THE OF THE PROPOSAL ADDRESS SO
WELL IDENTIFIED PROBLEM SO FOR
CERTAIN PIECES OF THE PROPOSAL
SUCH AS- OPPOSED FUNDING FOR
AUTOMATED RECYCLING MACHINES
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS OF THE WELL
KNOWN PROBLEM. OF CONSUMER
ACCESS ATTEMPTS. PLEASE CASES WE
THANK THE MINISTRY HASN'T
CLEARLY IDENTIFIED THE PROBLEM
OR HOW THE SPECIFI PROPOSAL
WOULD ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM SO
FOR EXAMPLE. PART OF THIS
PACKAGE IS A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A TEMPORARY CONSUMER
RECYCLING CREDIT. AND ACCORDING
TO ADMINISTRATION THAT'S
INTENDED TO KIND OF KNOW
INCREASE THE C. R. V. VALUE FOR-
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS THAT ARE
RETURNS WHERE PEOPLE WERE.
STORING THOSE BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS THEY WERE PURCHASED
OVER THAT PANDEMIC AND THEY JUST
HAVEN'T RETURNED THEM YET AND SO
THAT INCREASED CRP WHAT KIND OF
ENCOURAGE THAT. REDEMPTION OF
THOSE CONTAINERS- AND ARGUE IT'S
NOT REALLY CLEAR THERE HASN'T
BEEN A LOT OF GREAT IT'S
PRESENTED THAT. CONSUMERS ARE
CURRENTLY. THE DISH BRIDGE
CONTAINER- THAT PURCHASED AND M.
ANY IF THEY ARE IT'S UNCLEAR HOW
THE KIND OF TEMP. INCREASE IN
THE C. R. V. VALUE- WOULD
ENCOURAGE REDEMPTION THAT WOULD
NOT A NOT HAVE OTHERWISE
OCCURRED SO FOR EXAMPLE IF
CONSUMERS ARE STORY IN
SOMEBODY'S BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
PRESUMABLY IT'S WITH THE INTENT.
TO REDEEM THEM AT SOME POINT
AND- THE TEMPORARY INCREASE IN
THE C. R. V. COULD ESSENTIALLY
JUST SORT OF SHIFT THE TIMING ON
WHICH THEY RETURN THOSE
CONTAINERS AND NOT. AT THE
OVERALL NUMBER OF TRAINERS THAT
ARE RECYCLED. RUN SECOND.
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS HOW
EFFECTIVE ARE THE PROPOSALS AT A
CHEATING DIFFERENT RECYCLING
GOALS INCLUDING INCREASING
RECYCLING RATES AN INCREASE IN
THE- RETENTION OPPORTUNITIES
AVAILABLE TO. CONSUMERS AND
STUFF IN OUR VIEW THE
LEGISLATURE HASN'T PRESENTED
MUCH KIND OF INFORMATION ON KIND
OF WHAT OUTCOMES IT EXPECTS ON
THOSE DIFFERENT METRICS. AND SO
THE LEGISLATURE MY ONE ASTON
MINISTRATION TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION- IN THE
HEARING TODAY. AND GOING FORWARD
. THIRD RELATED TO THAT ISSUE
I'LL HAVE THE RESULTS FROM THE
EXISTING PILOTS INFORMED THIS
PROPOSAL SO AS THE COMMITTEE IS
LIKELY AWARE CAL RECYCLE IS
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO IMPLEMENT. FIVE PILOT
PROJECTS TO EXPLORE DIFFERENT
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES AND THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED AN
ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION DOLLARS
AS PART OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET TO
EXPAND THAT TO AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE PILOT PROJECTS- THE RESULTS
AND OUTCOMES FROM THOSE THE
EXISTING PILOTS HAVE NOT. BEEN
PRESENTED YET- ANDS OF THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO ASK
THE ADMINISTRATION TO REPORT ON
WHAT IT WHAT IS SEEN FROM THOSE
PILOTS SO FAR KEY LESSONS THAT
ARE LEARNED. AND HOW THOSE
PILOTS HAVE INFORMED THIS
PROPOSAL- IF THE RESULTS FROM
THOSE PILOTS AREN'T AVAILABLE
YET AND THE LATEST LEGISLATORS
COULD CONSIDER DELAYING SOME OF
THE FUN AT LEAST SOME OF THE
FUNDING- UNTIL MORE INFORMATION
IS AVAILABLE FROM THE RESULTS
ABOUT PILOT. BOTH PILOTS. AND
THEN FINALLY- DOES THE PROPOSAL
. GOING BENEFITS RECORD WHICH
PIECES OF THE PROPOSAL HAVE
ONGOING BENEFITS AND THE
LEGISLATURE MY WOULD CONSIDER
WAYS TO TARGET FUNDING TO
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE LIKELY TO
ENCOURAGE ONGOING RECYCLING
IMPROVE ON RECYCLING RATES AND
ACCESS RATHER THAN JUST ONE TIME
BENEFITS WE DO THINK SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS- HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
INCREASE RECYCLING ARE ONGOING
BASIS SUCH AS THE AUTOMATED.
AUTOMATED RECYCLING MACHINES AND
PROVIDING LOANS CYCLER IS THAT
ARE FORGIVEN IF THOSE LAWS ARE
OPERATING- FOR AT LEAST THREE
YEARS SO THOSE COULD HAVE SOME
MULTI YOUR BENEFITS IN OTHER
CASES SUCH AS THE INCREASE THE
R. V. THE TEMPORARY KIND OF
INCREASING CRP VALUES- WE THINK
ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE HAVE
RESULTS ON A LIMITED TERM BASIS
IF THEY DO HAVE- BENEFITS AND
SO. LEGISLATURE MY WANTED
CORRECTED MINISTRATION TO REPORT
ON WHICH OF THEIR PROPOSALS ARE
INTENDED TO HAVE- ONGOING
BENEFIT FOCUS ITS SPENDING IN
THOSE AREAS SO I'LL IN MY
COMMENTS THERE AND HAPPY ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU-
SERGEANT. AT IS IT POSSIBLE TO
SEND SOMEBODY OUTSIDE AND ASKED
THEM TO STOP WORKING OUT THERE
UNTIL NOON. FLEX FLEX A LITTLE.
FORTY I MEAN IT'S PRETTY
DISTRACTING RIGHT YEAH. WE'RE
GONNA TRY GREAT THANK YOU. SO
THE- WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM-
DEPARTMENT FINANCING YES- GOOD
MORNING CHAIR BLOOM AND MEMBERS
CHRISTIAN BELGIAN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO ECHO THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS REVIEWED AND
ANALYZED THE EXISTING FUND
BALANCE ND HAS CONCLUDED THAT
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION UP
FROM THE FUND BALANCE IS A PRINT
ALLOCATION OF RESOURCES FROM THE
EXISTING FUND BALANCE OF THE B.
C. R. F. THE CURRENT ESTIMATED
FUND BALANCE FOR BCRF IS
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION. IF THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVES THIS
PROPOSAL THE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES THAT BCRF WILL
MAINTAIN A PRUDENT LEVEL OF
PROJECTED RESERVES FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
THREE BUDGET YEAR OF-
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT MILLION HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAS. DIRECTOR YOUR- THE PROPOSAL
IS BASED ON- THE FACT THAT
THERE'S THIS EXTRA MONEY IN THE
ACCOUNT AND THE EXTRA MONEY AS A
RESULT OF INCREASED PURCHASES
DURING- THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC DO WE HAVE ANY OR IS
THERE ANY- THOUGHT THAT- THE
INCREASED AMOUNT OF PURCHASING
IS GOING TO CONTINUE ON IN THE
FUTURE. AND CHAPLAIN IS FOR THAT
QUESTION I ATE AT APPRECIATE
THAT AND HIGHLIGHTING THAT YES
SO AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC- UNLIKE OTHER TYPES OF
ECONOMIC- DISTURBANCES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED IN THIS FUND SOUGHT AN
INCREDIBLE INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF CONTAINERS THAT WERE BEING
PURCHASED THAT RESULTED IN AB AT
MUCH HIGHER- NUMBER OF THAT
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS PURCHASED
AND THEN AMOUNT ENOUGH OVERALL
FIND- WE HAVE SEEN THAT CONTINUE
TO DATE BUT OUR EXPECTATION IS
AS- WE GET TO OUR NEW NEW NORMAL
AS YOU SAY IT THAT WE WOULD SEE
A LEVELING UP. OFF AND A
DECREASE IN THAT OVERALL
PURCHASE SO IF WE JUST THINK
ANECDOTALLY OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR IN HOUSEHOLDS YES WE
PROBABLY WERE BUYING- CASES OF
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS BOTTLED
WATER CANNED- SO DOES ITS
ADDRESS AT DURING THE PANDEMIC
THAT NUMBER NO SODA I DON'T BY
STATE LOOK AT THAT THE-
SPARKLING. WATER IN. THE THING
IN OUR HOUSEHOLD THAT IS OUR OR
HEALTH. A LOT OF SPARKLY MY IN
OUR BUT AS THEY- AS WE AG BACK
AND THE WORKPLACE IT BACK IN A
RESTAURANT WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THOSE NUMBERS OF WELL DECREASE
AGAIN BACK TO MORE HISTORIC
NUMBERS AND THAT'S WHY THIS
PROPOSAL TREATS THIS AS AT ONE
TIME- FUNDING INCREASE AS
OPPOSED TO A NEW TRENDS WITHIN.
THE FUND. THANKS IT WAS SO HAVE
WE SEEN THE CURVE KINDA LEVEL
OFF YET OR IS IT STILL- WELL IT
IS. IT IS LEVELING AT THAT
HIGHER LEVEL RIGHT NOW- BUT
AGAIN THE WORLD IS- IS CHANGING
EVERY DAY- AND SO AGAIN HAPPY TO
COME BACK AND TALK TO THE
LEGISLATURE AGAIN IN THE
BEGINNING OF NEXT YEAR AFTER.
THAT PERHAPS THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED AGAIN TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THESE
TRENDS ARE BUT THE HISTORIC
TRENDS THAT WE HAVE USED FOR
FORECASTING. FOR MANY MANY YEARS
ARE NOT PLAYING OUT CURRENTLY SO
ONE CONCERN THAT I'VE HEARD
ABOUT THE- A PROPOSAL THAT YOU.
I THINK IT'S VERY- GUY MADE OF-
BUT ONE CONSERVER IS THAT- THAT
PEOPLE- OF ANTICIPATE THAT THE
RATE IS GOING TO GO. UP IN THE
FUTURE AND SO THE HOLD ON TO
THEIR RECYCLABLES AND HOARD THEM
ESSENTIALLY AND- WAIT FOR THE-
FOR THE REDEMPTION VALUE TO GO
UP- IS THERE A WAY TO PROTECT
AGAINST THAT. DO DID NOT SEE
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN IN
THE PAST WHEN REDEMPTION RATES
WENT UP AND HAD A- EXCUSE ME AT
REDEMPTION RATES BUT REDEMPTION
VALUE WENT UP- ABOUT A DECADE
AGO. WE DID NOT SEE THE TRENDS
REALLY- WHERE PEOPLE HALTED
THEIR RECYCLING AND THEN BROUGHT
THEM IN AT A LATER DATE. ALSO IN
OTHER STATES AS THEY BUMPED UP
THE REDEMPTION VALUE YOU DID NOT
SEE THAT KIND OF TREND WE HAVE
HEARD THIS CONCERN BROUGHT UP
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS-
THAT IT WAS ANECDOTALLY. ALREADY
HAPPENING I'M NOT REALLY SURE
HOW THAT DATA WOULD HAVE BEEN
COLLECTED BECAUSE NOTHING SINCE
APRIL FIRST WOULD HAVE BEEN
REPORTED. I INTO THAT PROGRAM
THAT WOULD GIVE US ANY
INDICATION THAT THAT WAS THE
CASE- SO IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT IF
THAT BECOMES AN IT BECOMES AN
ISSUE BUT THAT HAS NOT BEEN AN
ISSUE. THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST. WE DO YOU THINK I THINK IT
JUST IT ON THAT NOTE THAT- ROSS
PRODUCT. AND WAS THE PURPOSE OF
THIS OF GETTING THOSE OF BOTTLES
AND CANS THAT ARE. PERHAPS BEING
HELD IN PEOPLE'S GARAGES AND-
AND TODAY. IS THAT WE'RE NOT
SEEING THE BOTTLES AND CANS I'M
SHOWING UP IN LANDFILLS ARE ARE-
WASTE CHARACTERIZATIONS ARE NOT
SHOWING A HUGE INFLUX OF THESE
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS IS
RECYCLABLE CONTAINERS IN OUR
LANDFILLS TODAY. SO WE'RE NOT
REALLY SURE WHERE THEY'RE AT AND
THIS IS REALLY INTENDED. TO GET
WHATEVER IS OUT THERE BACK INTO
THE RECYCLING SYSTEM AND THEN
GET IT RE MANUFACTURED INTO NEW
BEVERAGE CONTAINER. HOW DO THE
INVEST SAID YOUR PER- TRANSLATE
INTO- A PERMANENT CHANGES AND-
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT
WAS A REALLY EXCELLENT QUESTION
AND CERRO. SOME OF OUR
INVESTMENTS ARE MEANT TO REALLY
BE- THAT BRIDGE BETWEEN NOW AND
WHEN WE WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO COME UP WITH SOME
OF THE LONGER TERM. SOLUTIONS SO
FOR INSTANCE WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTACT WITH OUR LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IS OUR STATE
CONSERVATION CORPS AND SOME
OTHER WORK FORCE- DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS TO DO MOBILE RECYCLING.
THAT WOULD BE A THREE TO FIVE
YEAR PROGRAM OBVIOUSLY NOT A
LONG TERM PROGRAM BUT REALLY
MEANT TO FACILITATE A QUICK
SOLUTION TO DATE TO OUR
RECYCLING DESERT'S THAT EXISTS.
TO GET THOSE RECYCLING
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE TO
PLACES LIKE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND EVEN SOME
OF OUR CITIES THAT- ARE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING-
REDEMPTION AND- AT A LACK OF
REDEMPTION OPPORTUNITIES AND SO.
THOSE ARE REALLY MEANT TO BE
QUICK TO PLACEMENT LET'S GET
RETIRED RECYCLING OPPORTUNITIES
OUT TO EVERY CALIFORNIA AND-
SEND SOME OF OUR SOLUTIONS ARE
TRULY MEANT. TO FACILITATE
LONGER TERM SOLUTIONS IN THIS
PROGRAM AND REALLY OPEN UP THIS
PROGRAM TO SOME NEW CREATIVE
VERY CALIFORNIA TYPE- KNOWLEDGE
B. LIKE THE REVERSE VENDING
MACHINES THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE DEPLOYED. TO RETAILERS AND-
OTHER AT STATE OR LOCAL
FACILITIES AND THAT WE WOULD
LOVE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW TO BUILD THAT
BUT A REVERSE VENDING MACHINE AS
WE ALL KNOW TAKES UP A LOT LESS
ROOM- THEN EACH TRUCK OR A
TRAILER. AND WE THINK THAT WE
COULD DEPLOY A QUITE A FEW OF
THOSE ACROSS THE STATE AND THEN
REALLY FACILITATE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THAT TECHNOLOGY-
AND- THE WIDESPREAD ACCEPTANCE
OF THAT TECHNOLOGY. AND A VERY.
TYPE OF PLACE ACROSS STATE AND
UNDER THE- THE UPPER CAL RECYCLE
PROPOSAL FOR REVERSE VENDING
MACHINES. UM THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD ESSENTIALLY SUBSIDIZE THE-
OF PLACEMENT OF A MACHINE- AND
THEN WHO WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR- MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION
COSTS IS SO I THINK IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON AND THE TYPE OF
CONTRACT THAT THE FACILITY WOULD
ENTER INTO SO LET'S TAKE FOR
INSTANCE- A RETAIL FACILITY
WHERE WE WOULD DEPLOY WE WERE
PERHAPS SUBSIDIZE THE UP FRONT
COST OF PURCHASING OR LEASING
THE- REVERSE VENDING MACHINE IT
WOULD THEN BE PLACED- IN THE
FACILITY OR AT THE GROCERY STORE
AND THEN THAT- FACILITY WOULD
CONTRACT WITH A COMPANY THAT
PROVIDED THE RIVER SPENDING
USING SO NOT UNLIKE. A VENDING
MACHINE FOR- NOT GONNA USE CANDY
INSTEAD OF IT. OTHER SNACKS THAT
YOU WOULD GET- IT WOULD BE A
SIMILAR TYPE OF CONTRACTING
SITUATION SO THIS WOULD REALLY
BE MEANT TO FACILITATE THOSE UP
FRONT COSTS AND THEN THE
FACILITIES WOULD WORK OUT
THROUGH A CONTRACT. WITH THE
WITH THE PROVIDER- THERE'RE- ARE
A MYRIAD OF OTHER ISSUES WITH
THE RECYCLING SYSTEM- FOR
EXAMPLE THE CO MINGLING OF
PLASTIC AND GLASS ON GLASS
BREAKAGE AND- HI AND SO FORTH
WHAT TO. WHAT WHAT WHAT KINDS OF
SOLUTIONS IT ARE YOU LOOKING AT
OR HOW DO YOU PROPOSE TO MOVE
FORWARD ON- THOSE- OTHER
PROBLEMS STILL ON THAT SPECIFIC
ISSUE WE ALSO GAVE A GREAT DEAL
THOUGHT TO THAT AND YOU HAVE IN
THE PROPOSAL THE TO. THE TO
AMOUNTS THAT WE WOULD PROVIDE
FOR THE TO QUALITY INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE REALLY MEANT
VERY SPECIFICALLY TO GET AT THAT
ISSUE- IT MAKES NO SENSE FOR US
TO GO TO GREAT LENGTHS TO TRY TO
RETRIEVE ALL THESE BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS IF IT IF ATTHE END
OF THE DAY. THEY END UP IN BALES
OR IN- A CONDITION THAT ISN'T
RECYCLABLE AND SO MAKING THOSE
INVESTMENTS IN- ARE. QUALITY
INCENTIVE AND- PLASTIC MATERIALS
PMDP DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM AND AT
HELPS WITH INSURING THAT THEY
THE MATERIALS THAT WE ARE
GETTING BACK IS AT THE HIGHEST
QUALITY AND RECYCLABLE AGAIN WE
WANT BEVERAGE CONTAINER TO
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
WE'VE GOT INVESTMENTS ACROSS-
OUR VARIOUS INDUSTRIES WHETHER
IT'S GLASS RECYCLING OR PLASTICS
RECYCLING OR ALUMINUM RECYCLING.
pHERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO TRULY CAPTURE AND RECYCLE
THOSE MATERIALS AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
MATERIALS IN THE BEST- POSSIBLE-
FORM AND ANNOUNCES THOSE
MATERIALS TO MAKE THEIR
BUSINESSES TRULY- CIRCUIT. HAVE
YOU CONSIDERED USING OF THE-
FUNDS THAT- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY. TO INSTALL WATER
REFILLING STATIONS AT SCHOOLS.
SOMEBODY I KNOW HAS A BILL ON
THE TOP- BUT THE BENEFIT OF THAT
WOULD BE- THE- LESS USAGE OF-
SINGLE USE PLASTICS PLASTICS I
THINK THAT WOULD IS M. AN
INNOVATIVE IDEA AND I THINK THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING WORTH
DISCUSSING THE LESS WE NEED-
SINGLE USE MATERIALS THE BETTER
OFF WE ARE. THIS WAS VERY MUCH
AT- STRUCTURED AROUND- THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS THAT ARE IN
THE SYSTEM BUT IF THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THE CHAIR WOULD
LIKE TO DISCUSS I'D BE HAPPY TO.
AYE OKAY I LEFT MY PROP ON MY
DESK AS I RUSHED OVER HERE-
MIKE- REUSABLE BOTTLE THAT SAYS-
WATER- WATER- ZERO GRAMS SUGAR
FOR THOSE OF A- YOU ARE
INTERESTED IN THAT ISSUE- BUT I
DO THINK THAT THAT MIGHT BE- AND
APPROPRIATE USE FOR- SOME OF
THOSE FUNDS. AT LAST QUESTION I
HAVE- RELATES TO- THE LANGUAGE
THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT
EXEMPTS ALL CURRENT LAWS
INCLUDING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PRACTICE ACT IN THE PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE REQUIREMENTS IS
THAT REALLY NECESSARY. WE WERE
REALLY FOCUSED ON VERY QUICKLY
DEPLOYING THE SOLUTIONS AND TO
GO THROUGH THE APA PROCESS OR
SOME OF THESE OTHER PROCESS SEES
REALLY DOESN'T GET- THE
SOLUTIONS DEPLOYED IN THE NEXT
YEAR IT REALLYIN THE ÁP PROCESS
ON YOU KNOW NORMAL TRACK TAKES
ANYWHERE FROM EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS AND SINCE THIS WAS
ONE TIME FUNDS- THAT WERE MEANT
TO ADDRESS A PROBLEM THAT I
THINK WE ALL AGREE IS THERE
TODAY. WE FELT THAT WE HAD
ENOUGH INFORMATION TO HAVE A
PUBLIC PROCESS TO HAVE AND- A
CONVERSATION WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS BUT RATHER HAD
ENOUGH INFORMATION THAT WE
DIDN'T NEED A NEW REGULATORY
PROCESS TO IMPLEMENT BUT RATHER
A NEST INFORMATION TO DEPLOY
VERY QUICKLY- SOME OF BASED ON
SOME OF THE EXPERIENCES WE'VE
HAD AROUND MOBILE RECYCLING OR
REVERSE VENDING MACHINES I THINK
AND OUR OUR REAL GOAL HERE WAS
TO DEPLOY AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. SO THAT THE PURPOSE OF
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SMITH. AND I'LL FOLLOW UP PRETTY
MUCH FOR THE VENDING MACHINES
DOCTORED ONE CANDID TIMER CAN I
DON'T MY WHOLE BAG IN THERE IS A
BY INDIVIDUAL BUT WAIT VOLUME
HOW IS IT CALCULATED AT SO IT
DEPENDS ON THE MACHINE RIGHT NOW
MOST OF THE MACHINES ARE ONE
CANADA TIME AND SO THIS WOULD
NOT BE TO FACILITATE SOMEBODY
BRINGING AND- YOU KNOW A
TRUCKLOAD OF- OF- ADD BOTTLES
AND CANS BUT RATHER IF YOU HAD A
BACK AS- FIFTY OR SO BUT I HAVE
HAD A CONGRESS. OF THE RIVER
SENDING ME. AT MANUFACTURERS
WHERE THEY ARE DEVISING SYSTEMS
THAT CAN- CAN I TAKE IN MORE
THAN ONE CONTAINER AND I
RECOGNIZE A TWELVE SCANNER
SIXTEEN OUNCE CAN VERSUS
SMASHED. TO A YOU KNOW GOOD OR
DOES IT HAVE TO BE NOT CRUSHED
BEFORE GOD AND I BELIEVE THAT
MOST OF THE MACHINES REQUIRE IT
TO NOT BE CRUSHED BUT THERE ARE
AGAIN THE DIFFERENT
MANUFACTURERS ARE DOING SOME
REALLY INTERESTING THINGS IN
TERMS OF THE DAY THE DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGY NOW- AND- THE
COMPUTERS WITHIN THE. SYSTEM TO
BE ABLE TO I F. BUT I. A I
SHOULD HAVE BROUGHT A PROMISE
BUT AT. KNOW THAT THE C. R. V.
LAIT HAS TO BE A- FOR IT TO RE
YEAH. YEAH EXACTLY. AND THEN.
HOW DO I PUT HIM IN THERE IS IT.
WITH THE REACH IF TO MARK OR-
PARTICULAR LIQUOR STORE I GET A
RECEIPT AND THEN I GOING TO GET
A REFUND FROM THE- VENDOR SO
SOME OF US ARE RECEIPTS WHERE
YOU CAN GET A REFUND RIGHT THERE
FROM THE VENDOR AND SOME OF THEM
WILL DEPOSIT DIRECTLY INTO A
BANK ACCOUNT IF YOU WOULD LIKE.
OBSERVER OF SOME REALLY
INTERESTING THINGS HAPPENING IN
THIS AREA OF TECHNOLOGY THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF COMPANIES. THAT
ARE REALLY EXCITED TO BE MORE
PRESENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THEM THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO FURTHER DEVELOP
THIS TECHNOLOGY SO. WE'RE REALLY
HOPING THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT CAN. GROW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA KIND OF A FOLLOW UP
IN TWO SO I'VE PUT. I GOT A BAG
OF LET'S JUST SAY FIFTY KHZ. I
GET TWENTY FIVE IN THERE IT IS
FULL. I STILL GOTTA KEEP MY
OTHER TWENTY HOW LONG DOES IT
TAKE HIM FOR SOMEONE TO COME TO
EMPTY THAT VENDING MACHINE
BEFORE I CAN COME BACK. I HAVE
AS I UNDERSTAND IT AS THIS IS
BEEN DEPLOYED AND STATES LIKE
OREGON AND MICHIGAN THAT THEY
ARE VERY QUICK TO- TO BE ABLE TO
DEPLOY PEOPLE TO DO IT TO COME
IN AND DO THE MACHINES AND THAT.
THERE IS A LOT OF CONNECTION
BETWEEN. THAT COMPANY WHO'S
MAINTAINING THE MACHINE AND THE
MACHINE ITSELF SO THEY KNOW WHEN
IT'S WITHIN TWENTY FIVE CANS OF
IT SAY THEY THEY THEY DO HAVE
THEMSELVES ON. AT LOGISTICS
SCHEDULES IT SAID RIGHT TO
MAINTAIN THE MACHINE SOMETIMES
SOME KIND OF ELECTRONIC SIGNAL
SENSOR NOBODY HAS COME AND
VISUALLY LOOK AT IT YEAH ALL OF
THE MAJOR THESE REVERSE VENDING
THE REPRESENTATIONS AND HAVE.
SOME PRETTY INTERESTING AT
TECHNOLOGY BUT COMPLEX COMPUTERS
IN THEM THAT ARE COMMUNICATING
AND SAID THE MAINTENANCE- THE
OVERALL MAINTENANCE COSTS FOR
THE COMPANIES HAVE BEEN.
DECREASING OVER TIME AS THEY
DEVELOP THEIR TECHNOLOGY MAYBE
JUST THE EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS
MAKE. SURE THEY DON'T SMASHED
THE CAN BECAUSE IT. RIGHT RIGHT
THAT IT YEAH THAT IS ONE OF THE
CHALLENGE WITH- SOME OF THE
TECHNOLOGY AND REVERSE VENDING
MACHINE BACKDROPS ET CETERA THE
COMPUTERS HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
READ THE CRB WHEELER BE ABLE TO
TRACK ALL RIGHT THIS MACHINE IS
IN THIS PARTICULAR AREA IT'S NOT
GETTING ANY ACTIVITY AND ANOTHER
ONE IS GETTING A LOT OF CAN WE
PUT TWO OF THEM IN THAT AREA AND
MOVE THEM AROUND THAT WAY TOO
EIGHT EXACTLY THAT IS
BENEFITS I THINK OF THIS
PARTICULAR TECHNOLOGY AGAIN
BECAUSE- THEY- HAVE THESE-
COMPUTER SYSTEMS AND THEN. THAT
THE ABILITY TO COLLECT SPECIFIC
DATA ABOUT. THE KINDS OF
MATERIALS THAT ARE COMING BACK
WHEN THEY'RE COMING BACK AT HOW
MUCH A MACHINE IS BEING USED
WILL BE- ONE OF THE FUNCTIONS OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY. I AM AM I
CORRECT THAT- WHAT THE-
REDEMPTION VALUE IS RETURNED TO
THE CONSUMER IN THE FORM OF A-
CREDIT- FOR USE AT TO A- OKAY I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE EVER USED
THE COINSTAR MACHINES- BUT I
USED TO OUR- CLIENTS AND THAT
WAS A GOOD PLACE TO RETURN- BUT
YOU WOULD GET THERE YOU GET A
COUPON BACK FOR AND YOU CAN
CHOOSE- EITHER I THINK FOR THE
STORE- CREDIT AT THE STORE THAT
YOU'RE- IN. OR THROUGH AMAZON
OR- OTHER PLACES TOO AND OUR
CURRENT STATUTE REQUIRES THAT
YOU HAVE AVAILABILITY TO CASH
RIGHT ON THE SPOT SO- ALL RIGHT
SOME OF- IT I WOULD THINK AT A
RETAILER IF IT WERE GOING TO
MEET THAT STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE ABLE TO GET
CASH ON THE SPOT BUT SAY YOU
KNOW SOMEONE HAD SUGGESTED AND
ONE OF OUR MEETINGS. WHEN THIS
BE INTERESTING TO DEPLOY A AT
SAY A LIBRARY WALL LIBRARY
OBVIOUSLY IS NOT GOING TO HAVE A
CASH BOX SITTING THERE TO DEPLOY
BUT THAT FACILITY COULD PERHAPS
HAVE SOMETHING THAT- WOULD BE A
CREDIT THAT YOU COULD USE OR
AGAIN. AND IF YOU HAVE A PAYPAL
OR VENMO ACCOUNT OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT THAT THAT MONEY CAN GO
DIRECTLY FROM THE MACHINE INTO
YOUR ACCOUNT SO THERE ARE SOME
OF REALLY INNOVATIVE IDEAS- THAT
AGAIN IF WE ARE. LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITY BUT NOT NECESSARILY
TO MEET EVERY SINGLE REQUIREMENT
UNDER THE STATUTE THIS IS A
GREAT WAY TO DO THAT AND IT WILL
HELP DEVELOP THE TECHNOLOGY EVEN
FURTHER. GREAT WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
OF THERE'S NO MORE QUESTIONS
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
EXCELLENT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR PLEDGES SEEN.
I THINK OUR FRIENDLY-
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS OUTSIDE OF
. DECIDED TO RETALIATE BY
PICKING UP EVEN NOISIER TOOLS.
OKAY MAYBE WE CAN SEND SOME OF
THE FOLKS WHO WERE IN THE
HALLWAY OUT TO. TALK TO THEM. MR
A- KNOCKED OUR WELCOME. ISSUE
NUMBER TWO IS IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT THE SIGMA PROGRAM
YEAH THANK YOU AND GOVERNMENT
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THE
GROUNDWATER IS A CRUCIAL
RESOURCE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SIGMA IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO CREATE PLANS TO
MANAGE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY SUSTAINABLY- MANY
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES SUBMITTED THEIR PLANS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
FOR THEIR EVALUATION- THE
DEPARTMENT HAS FOUND TWELVE OF
THOSE BASINS TO HAVE INCOMPLETE
PLANS FOR A RANGE OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES. WHICH MEANS THE BOARD
MAY BE CALLED UPON FOR ITS
PRIMARY ROLE IN SIGMA WHICH IS
TO INTERVENE IN BASINS WHERE
PLANS HAVE BEEN FOUND DEFICIENT
TO PROTECT DRINKING WATER AND
OTHER WATER USES SO THIS SPRING
FINANCE LETTER IS A REQUEST TO
EXPAND OUR SEGMENTS HEME- SO
THAT WE CAN CARRY OUT THOSE
IMPORTANT ROLES. GREAT TO HAVE-
REPORT. GOOD MORNING AVERAGE
EILERS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE NICE TO SEE YOU
IN PERSON- WE DON'T RAISE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL HOWEVER WE JUST WANNA
FLAG FOR YOU THAT THIS ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION- THAT'S BEING
REQUESTED IS ONGOING GENERAL
FUND AND THE SIGMA LEGISLATION
ORIGINALLY CONTEMPLATED THAT
THIS OVERSIGHT REGULATORY ROLE
BY THE WATER BOARD WOULD BE
FUNDED BY FEES OF AFFECTED-
GROUNDWATER BASINS. SO IT IS IT
YOU KNOW IT'S KIND OF PREMATURE
AT THIS POINT AS THINGS ARE JUST
GETTING UP AND RUNNING TO
IDENTIFY WHO WOULD PAY AND WHAT
THE RATES WOULD BE AND BE ABLE
TO COLLECT THE MONEY TO FUND THE
STAFF THAT ARE NEEDED
IMMEDIATELY BUT IT IS SOMETHING
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
PROBABLY WILL WANT TO REVISIT IN
A FEW YEARS AS- AS THOSE
STRUCTURES AND FEES CHARGING M.
SYSTEMS CAN BE PUT IN PLACE-
BECAUSE AGAIN THE ORIGINAL
INTENTION IS THAT THIS WOULD BE
A- KIND OF BENEFICIARY PAYS TYPE
APPROACH RATHER THAN A GENERAL
FUND SUPPORTED ACTIVITY. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT
CRYSTAL SURE. POSTER HERE
CRYSTALS ARE THE DEPARTMENT OF
LAND RAFIA- I JUST WANTED TO
SORT OF FOLLOW UP ON THE
COMMENTS FROM THE ALLEY- TO JUST
FULLY ACKNOWLEDGE- THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AGREES THAT
ULTIMATELY THE INTENT OF SIGMA
WAS- THAT THAT FEES WOULD PAY
FOR THE WORK ABOUT THE WATER
BOARD THAT'S INCLUDED IN THIS
PROPOSAL- BUT ALSO ECHO THE
UNCERTAINTY
OF HOW THE FEES WOULD BE SET.
AND ALSO THERE'S GOING TO BE A
LAG- IN WHEN THOSE FEES ARE
COLLECTED SO AT THIS POINT WE
THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO PROVIDE
SOME ONGOING GENERAL FUND JUST
GIVEN THE CRITICAL NATURE OF- OF
THIS WORK AND WE FULLY INTEND ON
REVISITING THIS IN THE FUTURE
ULTIMATELY I'M SHIFTING- THESE
RESOURCES. AS APPROPRIATELY TO
THE FEES. THANK YOU I'VE JUST
BEEN INFORMED. THAT UNTIL NOON.
THAT IS GOING TO STOP. THAT MAY
BE THE MOST IMPORTANT ACTION
pTHAT I'VE BEEN HERE. AND I CAN
TELL YOU ALL APPRECIATE IT- WHAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT REPORT- I'M
IS NOT POWER- Y. A. DOES THIS
ACTION NOT QUALIFY FOR A- A
SEQUEL A CATEGORICAL EXEMPTION.
SO UNDER UNDERSTOOD MASS WRITTEN
A SEQUEL- IS REQUIRED FOR A
STATE WATER BOARD INTERIM
PLANNED ACTIVITIES- IT WAS JUST
HOW HOW STIGMA WAS WAS DRAFTED-
EVEN THOUGH OUR ROLE IN SEGMENT
IS INTENDED TO BE ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS- M. AND- TO. GET OUT OF
THE WAY AGAIN AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE FOR LOCAL- FOR-
UNENCUMBERED LOCAL MANAGEMENT-
YEAH IT WAS IT WAS DRAFTED TO
INCLUDE SEQUOIA SO THE SEQUEL
REQUIREMENTS ARE ACTUALLY
DRAFTED INTO. THE SEGMENT PLAN
OR SIGMA DOES NOT EXEMPT THE
STATE WATER BOARDS INTERIM
PLANNING PROCESS FROM SEQUEL-
THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WOULD DO SO- THAT THE
GOAL THERE WOULD BE TO ENSURE
THE STATE WATER BOARD CAN ACT IN
THESE BASINS THAT HAVE BEEN
FOUND DEFICIENT IN A IN A TIMELY
MANNER BUT- SO BUT MY QUESTION
IS WHETHER OR- A- CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTION WOULD EXIST IN ANY
EVENT- I'M NOT SURE. I DON'T
THINK SO. I'M. ONE OPTION- THAT
WE COULD HAVE IF I COULD- THAT
UTILIZE SIMPLY WANTED TO WOULD
BE TO JUST PROVIDE THE FUNDING
FOR A- A SEQUEL AND ALICE'S IS
THERE A REASON- WHAT WHAT WHAT
WOULD HE REASON BE FOR NOT
DOING THAT- THAT WOULD BE AN
OPTION THAT IS THAT IS AN
APPROACH THE LEGISLATURE COULD
TAKE IT IT WOULD STILL DELAY-
THE PROCESS OF STATE
INTERVENTION WHERE IT WHERE IT
IS NEEDED- BY BY A COUPLE OF
YEARS POTENTIALLY AND THEN- CAN
YOU. TELL US WHAT THE-
CONSEQUENCES OF- WAITING A
COUPLE YEARS WOULD BE YEAH THE
SIGNAL WAS DESIGNED TO ADDRESS A
WHOLE RANGE OF UNDESIRABLE
RESULTS INCLUDING. A DEPLETION
OF GROUNDWATER LEVELS THAT CAUSE
PEOPLE ON SHALLOW GROUNDWATER
WELLS TO RUN OUT OF WATER- OTHER
UNDESIRABLE RESULTS INCLUDE A
SUBSIDENCE OF THE LAND SURFACE
THAT CAN BREAK OR DISRUPT
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND SO DELAYS IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATE
WATER BOARDS ROLE- THROUGH
THROUGH STATE INTERVENTION-
WOULD ALLOW A LOT OF. GROUND
WATER CONDITIONS EITHER WORSEN
OR OR CONTINUE- IN A IN A
PROBLEMATIC WAY. THANK YOU CAN
I. ADD SOMETHING- SO I JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT-
CURRENTLY- UNDER UNDER STIGMA
WHEN A GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCY- IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVELOPING SORT
OF THE PLAN THEY HAVE A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION SO THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE BEFORE YOU IS
ESSENTIALLY PROVIDING. AN
EQUIVALENT- ACTUALLY MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT LESSER SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR THE STATE BOARD IN
THOSE EVENTS WHERE THEY HAVE TO
TAKE OVER THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
DEVELOPING THE INTERIM PLAN SO
IT'S JUST A KIND OF PROVIDE SOME
CONSISTENCY- WITH THE
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES WHEN THEY'RE DEVELOPING
THESE PLANS. SO CERTAINLY WE
COULD PROVIDE SOME FUNDING FOR A
SEQUEL COMPLIANCE BUT WE JUST
KNOW THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE A
POTENTIALLY SEVERAL MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS- YOU KNOW FOR EACH BASIN
A LITTLE TAMALE FALLS UNDER THE
WATER BOARD SO WE THINK THAT
THIS IS- THE CORRECT WAY TO SORT
OF REDUCE COSTS. ON THE STATE
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH- IF THE
LOCALS WERE- TAKING ON THESE
ACTIONS AND THEN ALSO IT IT-
EXPEDITE SOME OF THE WORK HERE-
AS MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED. GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISTER SMITH QUESTIONS. EXCUSE
ME IF WE CAN HAVE AN EXEMPTION
FOR THE SEQUEL FOR THE- SIGMA.
CAN WE EXEMPT UP FOR WATER
STORAGE PROJECTS FROM PROP ONE
THAT WE GET INTO FOR TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN TO START GET
SOME OF THESE WATER PROJECTS
MOVING A LOT QUICKER BECAUSE OF
THE SITE SO I THINK IT I WANT TO
SEE OUR SAY FORTY EIGHT OF FIFTY
YEARS WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR CAN
WE WAIVE THE EXEMPTION OR CAN
THE GOVERNOR TO AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER IN START WATER PROJECTS.
STORAGE RIGHT NOW. SO I DON'T
HAVE A AN ANSWER FOR YOU
IMMEDIATELY OBVIOUSLY THOUGH THE
WATER STORAGE PROJECTS OR I'M A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT IN THAT
THEY WERE- SET IN. AND VINYL
WHICH DOES NOT INCLUDE AS YOU AS
YOU MENTIONED KIND OF A CURRENCY
FOR EXEMPTION SO. I DON'T KNOW
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD I DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING THAT WOULD
NECESSARILY PRECLUDE- A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION BUT WOULD JUST TO SAY
THAT THE PROCESS THAT'S BEEN
ESTABLISH AND- IN PROP ONE IS.
IS SOMEWHAT PURPOSEFUL AND THAT
THERE ARE SEVERAL STEPS THAT
KIND OF NEED TO BE- THEY NEED TO
BE TAKEN. I THINK THE OTHER
THING HERE IS THAT WE'RE THERE
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS TOO QUICK
SECTION FOR THE FOR THE- THE
WATER BOARD A STATE ENTITY TO.
TO DO THAT WORSE IS THE PROP ONE
PROJECTS WHICH ARE REALLY. I'M
KIND OF LOCALLY DRIVEN- PROJECTS
AND I WOULD ALSO ADD THAT. THE
WATER STORAGE INVESTMENT PROGRAM
IS UNDERTAKING CONSTRUCTION
RELATED ACTIVITIES- IN MANY
CASES WHEREAS THE STATE WATER
BOARDS INTERIM PLAN ACTIVITIES
ARE. UNLIKELY DO SO THESE ARE
MORE LIKELY TO BE- RESTRICTIONS
ON PUMPING FOR EXAMPLE OR
REQUIREMENTS TO COLLECT
INFORMATION. RATHER THAN ACTUAL-
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES. FOR
WATERFORD AND THEN- ZERO GROUND
WATER SYSTEM WILL AGENCIES HAVE
A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS TO FIX THE
PLANS SHOULD NEVER BE PROPOSALS
THAT INCLUDE SOME FUNDING TO
HELP HIM GET IN COMPLIANCE- YES
THE STATE WATER BOARD AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
HAVE GOTTEN- FUNDING OVER THE
YEARS FOR A WHOLE RANGE OF
SIGMA. RELATED ASSISTANCE
EFFORTS OF THE DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN LEADING THE WAY IN THIS- IN
IN IN PART ACTUALLY GETTING
GETTING THIS- SPRING FINANCE
LETTER FUNDED THROUGH GENERAL
FUND IS ACTUALLY ANOTHER WAY OF
REDUCING COSTS TO LOCALS- IN THE
INTERIM BASIS BECAUSE OTHERWISE
THESE ACTIVITIES WOULD BE
FUNDED. THROUGH FEES. AT ONE
TIME AND I THINK I HEARD YOU'RE
RIGHT THERE'S ONLY TWELVE OF
CURRENTLY AGENCIES THAT ARE NOT
IN COMPLIANCE THEIR TWELVE
GROUNDWATER BASINS THAT ARE OUT
OF COMPLIANCE SOME OF SOME OF
THOSE HAVE SEVERAL AGENCIES IN
THEM- IT DIDN'T HELP. MESSAGE
CENTER. CENTRAL NORTHERN
SOUTHERN ARE ALL TWELVE OF THEM.
THERE IS A LARGE OTHER LARGE
LARGELY IN THE SOUTHERN CENTRAL
VALLEY OKAY- THANK YOU. FOR NOW
. WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE PRESENTATIONS APPRECIATED
WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE OIL AND GAS AND
FORSMAN COMMUNITY PROTECTION.
WE'VE GOT TO THEIR RESOURCES
BOARD. HERE TO PRESENT.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING I
THINK YOU CHAIR BLOOMIN MEMBERS
I MY NAME'S HEATHER KAROS I'M
ASSISTANT DIVISION CHIEF FOR
CARBS ENFORCEMENT DIVISION. AND
I'M GOING TO DISCUSS TODAY- ARE
PROPOSAL FOR OIL AND GAS
ENFORCEMENT AND COMMUNITY
PROTECTION- CARB IS REQUESTING A
TOTAL OF SIX PERMANENT POSITIONS
TO IMPLEMENT THIS INITIATIVE-
THREE OF THE NEW POSITIONS AS
WELL AS TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR IN CONTRACT FUNDS WILL BE
USED FOR STAFF TRAINING- TO
FOCUS EXCLUSIVELY ON EMPLOYEE.
INITIATIVE AT OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA- THESE POSITIONS AND
CONTRACT DOLLARS WILL BE FUNDED
BY THE OIL AND GAS GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUND- AT AN
ANNUAL COST OF SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND THE OTHER THREE NEW
POSITIONS WILL FOCUS ON
IMPLEMENTING THE INITIATIVE AT
OIL AND GAS IMPORTATION REFINING%
AND DISTRIBUTION FACILITIES-
THESE POSITIONS WILL BE FUNDED
BY THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
FUND AT AN ANNUAL COST OF SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS- CAL JIM IT REGULATES
THE EXTRACTION OF OIL AND GAS
FROM WELLS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS REGULATE-
EMISSIONS FROM OIL AND GAS WELLS
AND OTHER SOURCES OF EMISSIONS
CARBS ROLE IS TO REGULATE AND
ENFORCE GREENHOUSE GAS PROGRAMS
AND OVERSEE DISTRICT EMISSION
REDUCTION REGULATORY. PERMITTING
AND ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS- THE
PURPOSE OF THIS PIECE P. TO
ASSESS OIL AND GAS FACILITIES
COMPLIANCE WITH AIR QUALITY
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO RESPOND
TO OVER ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FORMAL COMPLAINTS RECEIVED BY
CARP. FROM LOCALS INCLUDING
THOSE FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND TO COLLABORATE
WITH AIR DISTRICTS TO ENSURE
THAT LOCAL AIR REGULATIONS ARE
DELIVERING ON THEIR PURPOSE TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH- THIS
INITIATIVE WILL INCLUDE REGULAR
INSPECTIONS AND REVIEWS THAT
THESE FACILITIES- ALLOWING CARP
STAFF IN CONSULTATION WITH
RELEVANT. REGULATORY AGENCIES TO
PRODUCE SUMMARY REPORTS THAT
DETAIL COMPLIANCE STATUS- MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR PROGRAMMATIC
IMPROVEMENT AND IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ADDITIONAL
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS- THIS
PROPOSAL IS NOT FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A NEW PROGRAM-
BUT IT IS A REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT STAFF TO
ADDRESS A NEED IN OUR CURRENT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT COVERED BY
EXISTING. RESOURCES EXAMPLES OF
EXISTING PROGRAMS INCLUDE CARBS
STUDY OF NEIGHBORHOOD ERROR NEAR
PETROLEUM SOURCES OR SNAPS-
CHARACTER WHICH CHARACTERIZES
THE AIR QUALITY AND COMMUNITIES
NEAR OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
FACILITIES AND INCLUDES A HEALTH
ASSESSMENT CONDUCTED BY- WE
HAVE. AND CARBS COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION PROGRAM FOCUSES ON
REDUCING EXPOSURE AND
COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED BY AIR
POLLUTION I'M COMMUNITIES AROUND
THE STATE ARE WORKING TOGETHER
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT NEW
STRATEGIES TO MEASURE AIR
POLLUTION AND REDUCED HEALTH
IMPACTS- THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
STATEWIDE EFFORT INCLUDES
COMMUNITY AIR MONITORING AND
COMMUNITY MISSIONS. REDUCTION
PROGRAMS HOWEVER AS MENTIONED
CARB IS RECEIVING COMPLAINTS
ABOUT OIL AND GAS FACILITIES
SPECIFICALLY- THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS- SO APPROVING THIS
PROPOSAL WILL HELP CURB BETTER
UNDERSTAND AND ADDRESS THESE
COMPLAINTS AS WELL AS INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY TO HELP BUILD TRUST
BETWEEN COMMUNITIES IN AIR
QUALITY REGULATOR- THE RESULTS
OF REPORTS REVIEWS AND
INSPECTIONS FROM THIS PROGRAM.
WILL HELP TO DIRECTLY ADDRESS AT
THE FACILITY LEVEL ANY POTENTIAL
EMISSIONS SOURCES IDENTIFIED
THROUGH MONITORING AND CONCERNS
RAISED TO CARVE THROUGH
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT- WHAT THIS
MIGHT LOOK LIKE- CARDS STAFF
RECENTLY CONDUCTED JOINT
INSPECTIONS WITH LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS STAFF IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. IN FOR OIL AND
GAS FIELDS NEAR THE CITIES OF
SHAFTER IN ARBIN AND DURING
THESE INSPECTIONS CARB STAFF
NOTED THREE LEAKS IN EXCESS OF
ONE THOUSAND PARTS PER MILLION
METHANE. AND IDENTIFIED
EQUIPMENT OPERATING ON SITE THAT
WAS NOT COVERED BY LOCAL
DISTRICT PERMIT- SO CARDSTOCK
REFERRED REFERRED THESE ISSUES
TO THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICT- WHICH
ISSUED A NOTICE OF VIOLATION SO
THIS PROPOSAL. WOULD PROVIDE
NEEDED RESOURCES TO INCREASE OUR
ENFORCEMENT CAPABILITIES IN
ORDER TO SERVE AND PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FROM HARMFUL AIR
POLLUTION. BY ENSURING THAT
STATE AND LOCAL POLICIES ARE
DELIVERING BENEFITS AS THEY WERE
INTENDED- THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MISTER BROWN. THANK
YOU AGAIN- SO FOR THIS PROPOSAL
WE DON'T HAVE ANY ISSUE WITH
KIND OF THE STATED GOALS OF
COURSE OF THE PROPOSAL OF- KIND
OF- INSURING MONITORING AND
COMPLIANCE WITH GREENHOUSE GAS
REGULATIONS AND LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION- OUR MAIN ISSUES I
THINK ARE KIND OF AROUND YOU
KNOW WHO CAN WHETHER THIS IS
KIND OF THE HIGHEST PRIORITY USE
OF RESOURCES AND KIND OF WHO
CONDUCTS THESE ACTIVITIES MORE
OF THE EXISTING LEVEL OF
RESOURCES SO. WE RECOMMEND IN
THE LEGISLATURE ASKED THE
ADMINISTRATION REPORT ON SOME OF
THESE ISSUES HERE AT THE HEARING
TODAY- ADULT RUN THROUGH I THINK
REALLY THE THREE MAIN QUESTIONS
THAT WE HAVE ONE IS. WHY SHOULD
THE STATE FOCUS ITS LIMITED
RESOURCES ON MONITORING OIL AND
GAS EXTRACTION FACILITIES RATHER
THAN OTHER SOURCES OF POLLUTION-
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN MANY HEAVILY
POLLUTED COMMUNITIES MOBILE
SOURCES- SUCH AS DIESEL TRUCKS
AND EQUIPMENT ARE REALLY THE
PRIMARY SOURCES OF AIR POLLUTION
AND SO. A QUESTION OUR MIND IS
WHY YOU KNOW THE MINISTRATION
FOCUS KIND OF ITS LIMITED
RESOURCES HERE ON OIL AND GAS
FACILITIES RATHER THAN SOME OF
THESE OTHER SOURCES OF
POLLUTION- SECOND. WHY ISN'T.
AND OF NEW UNIT AT LEAST THAT
WAS KIND OF HOW WE UNDERSTOO
THE PROPOSAL THAT PERHAPS-
PERHAPS THERE ISN'T A NEW UNIT
BUT NEW RESOURCES AT LEAST
NEEDED- AT CARB CARB ALREADY
HAS. SOME EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
STAFF RESOURCES AS WAS MENTIONED
THAT ARE DEDICATED TO SIMILAR
ACTIVITIES FOR EXAMPLE THE-
STUDY OF NEIGHBORHOOD ERROR-
NEAR PETROLEUM SOURCES TO
CHARACTERIZE AIR QUALITY IN
COMMUNITIES NEAR OIL AND GAS
FACILITIES. THE GREAT BRITAIN
TOXICS REPORTING REGULATION AND
OTHER RESOURCE- RESEARCH EFFORTS
IN THIS AREA. THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT ONE ASK CARP TO EXPLAIN
WHY THESE EXISTING PROGRAMS ARE.
AND RESOURCES ARE INSUFFICIENT
AND TO MEET ITS GOALS. AND
FINALLY EVEN IF MORE RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
OF OIL AND GAS FACILITIES AND
REFINERIES WHY IS. CAR BURLY
KIND OF THE BEST ENTITY TO
CONDUCT THESE EFFORTS SO AS I'M
SURE YOU KNOW GENERALLY LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS ARE. HAVE THE
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY FOR
REGULATING- THE STATIONARY
SOURCES OF AIR POLLUTION AND SO.
WHY ARE RESEARCH MORE RESOURCES
NEEDED A CAR RATHER THAN LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS SO I WILL IN MY
COMMENTS THEY'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR BLOOMIN
MEMBERS BRANDON MEREDITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS CONCLUDED THAT
THIS OIL AND GAS PROPOSALS
PRUDENT ALLOCATION OF RESOURCES
THAT IS COMPLEMENTARY TO
EXISTING RESOURCES. AND SERVICES
TO EXPAND UPON CRITICAL
EMISSIONS COMPLIANCE AND
OVERSIGHT FOR THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY. THE SIX POSITIONS WILL
SERVE TO BOLSTER LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS MONITORING FUNCTIONS
AND PROVIDE MORE TIMELY
RESPONSE. TO COMPLAINTS FROM
LOCAL COMMUNITIES REGARDING
NOXIOUS AND POTENTIALLY HARMFUL
EMISSIONS FROM THESE OIL AND GAS
FACILITIES. THANK YOU AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMITTEE HOUSE. THANK
YOU- MISSED A CURIOUS DO YOU
WANT TO TAKE A STAB AT ANSWERING
THE THREE QUESTIONS THAT TO.
MISTER BROWN ASKED SAID THE
FIRST ONE WAS- WHY FOCUS ON THE
SOURCE OF POLLUTION SURE- SO. I
THINK AND I THINK PART OF THE
QUESTION IS WHY NOT MOBILE
SOURCES FOR EXAMPLE SO CARP
ALREADY HAS EXTENSIVE AND
TRANSPARENT- ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON REGULATIONS
THAT WE ENFORCE DIRECTLY-
ESPECIALLY ON MOBILE SOURCES-
BUT WE'RE FOCUSING THIS REQUEST
ON OIL AND GAS EXTRACTION
DISTRIBUTION AND REFINING
BECAUSE THESE PROCESSES ARE A
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF AIR
EMISSIONS- AND SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE CARPETS RECEIVED- A
LITTLE OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FORMAL COMPLAINTS
RELATED TO REFINERIES AND OIL
GAS. AND OIL AND GAS FIELD
OPERATIONS- AND THESE COMPLAINTS
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE ORDERS
HEALTH EFFECTS FROM AIR
POLLUTION EMISSIONS- MONITORED
EXCESS EMISSIONS BLACK SMOKE AND
FLARING- ALSO IN RESPONSE TO
FEEDBACK FROM THE COMMUNITY AND
THROUGH OUR EIGHTY SIX ONE SEVEN
PRO- WHICH CARBON STOP WISHED
I'M SORRY CARCASS OUT WHICH THE
COMMUNITY- PROTECTION PROGRAM
THROUGH AB SIX ONE SEVEN. AM TO
REDUCE EXPOSURE IN COMMUNITIES
MOST IMPACTED BY AIR POLLUTION-
AND MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES
SELECTED THROUGH THAT PROGRAM-
CONTAIN OR ARE LOCATED ADJACENT
TO OIL AND GAS FACILITIES- AND
SO AS AN EXAMPLE WILMINGTON'S
TWENTY EIGHTEEN- COMMUNITY
EMISSION REDUCTION PLAN-
INCLUDED TWO OF THEIR TOP AIR
QUALITY QUALITY PRIORITIES
INVOLVED WELL- ADMISSIONS FROM
OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS- AND MANY
OTHER COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
RICHMOND IN THE BAY AREA AND
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY ARE EXPRESSING THE SAME
SENTIMENT TO US- AND SO. WE'RE
PUTTING FORWARD THIS INITIATIVE-
IN THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TO
HELP DIRECTLY ANSWER COMPLAINTS
AND CONCERNS- RAISED BY LAW
UNITIES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
ADDRESSED- BY THE LOCAL AGENCIES
THUS FAR. THANK YOU- AUNT- WHY
A- SECOND QUESTION WAS WHY A- A
NEW UNIT OR PROGRAM WHY NOT USE
EXISTING. PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES
YEAH- SO THIS- TO CLARIFY IS NOT
A NEW PROGRAM IT WOULD JUST BE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES- TO ADDRESS
A CRITICAL NEED AND ART IN OUR
EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT ISN'T
COVERED BY EXISTING RESOURCES-
AND SO THE PROPOSAL THAT E HAVE
HERE WOULD BE COMPLEMENTARY TO
OUR EXISTING AIR MONITORING
PROGRAMS- SUCH AS THE REFINERY
FENCE LINE AND SNAPS. AND THE
COMMUNITY MONITORING ENGAGEMENT
PROGRAMS- HARBINGERS EVEN COMPLY
GAME CARDS RECEIVING COMPLAINTS
ABOUT OIL AND GAS FACILITIES
SPECIFICALLY SO THE AIR
MONITORING IS A LITTLE MORE
HOLISTIC AND WERE RECEIVING
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE FACILITIES
MORE SPECIFICALLY- AND THAT OUR
EXISTING PROGRAMS AREN'T REALLY
DESIGNED TO ANSWER OR
INVESTIGATE THOSE TYPES OF
CONCERNS- AND SO BY WORKING WITH
FAIR DISTRICTS STAFF- WE CAN
BETTER UNDERSTAND AND ADDRESS
THESE COMPLAINTS AND WORK TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY- WHICH
WILL HELP BUILD TRUST BETWEEN
THE COMMUNITIES AND AIR QUALITY
REGULATORS- AND THEN WHAT WE CAN
DO IS USE. THE RESULTS OF THEIR
REPORTS AND INSPECTIONS ETCETERA
THAT WE OBTAIN THROUGH OUR IN
DEPTH ANALYSIS- TO- TO HELP
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS- AND SO
AGAIN THE REQUEST IS MORE
COMPLIMENTARY TO OUR EXISTING
RESOURCES- FILLING SORT OF A GAP
THAT WE DON'T HAVE AT THE
MOMENT. WHICH IS WHY YOU THINK
UP A CARP IS BEST SITUATED TO
HOW TO ADDRESS THESE IS RIGHT SO
CARB SO CAL JIM- REGULATE SORT
OF THE EXTRACTION BUT THE LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS REGULATE AIR
EMISSIONS AND THEN CORPORATE
TEENS OVERSIGHT SO CARBS ROLE
HERE IS A LITTLE BIT TWO FOLD SO-WE- HAVE OUR METHANE EMISSIONS
REGULATION- THAT WE'VE ADOPTED
IN THAT WE DIRECTLY ENFORCE- AND
THEN CARP ALSO HAS OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES OVER THE LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS- AND SO. BYE BYE
IN MINISTRY IN THOSE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES AND
INVESTIGATING OUR OWN
REGULATIONS- WILL BE ABLE WERE
IN SORT OF A BETTER POSITION TO
ENSURE MORE CONSISTENT AND
ROBUST ENFORCEMENT OF STATE AND
LOCAL RULES- TO EVALUATE
COMPLIANCE AND- MAKE SURE YOU
KNOW IDENTIFY ANY SORT OF
PROGRAMMATIC IMPROVEMENTS THAT
MIGHT NEED TO BE MADE. EIGHT
THANK YOU- I GUESS I WOULD HAVE-
AT- THAT THIS REQUEST IS RATHER
MODEST AT SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS AND IF WE
WERE TO- ASK ANOTHER AGENCY TO
DO IT I CAN'T IMAGINE THE
REQUEST WOULD BE ANY LESS SO.
ANY OF ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS MR
FONG. I MAY HAVE MISSED THIS OR
MAYBE I CAN ASK FOR
CLARIFICATION- WHY I THINK THE
THIRD QUESTION FROM DELEO IS WHY
NOT THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS.
INSTEAD OF CARP. REYES THE LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS DO DIRECTLY
REGULATE- THE SOURCES OF
EMISSIONS- BUT AGAIN- CARB IS
RECEIVING SEVERAL COMPLAINTS
ABOUT ISSUES- THAT THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING FROM THE SOURCES
AND SO CARB. THROUGH ITS DIRECT
ENFORCEMENT OF OUR METHANE
REGULATIONS AND OUR OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES CAN SURE ENSURE
MORE CONSISTENT SORT OF
STATEWIDE ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE.
PROVIDE A SUPPORT TO THE
DISTRICTS- TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE-
AND YOU KNOW IDENTIFIES SORT OF
ANY HOLISTIC- PROBE PROGRAMMATIC
IMPROVEMENTS THAT MAYBE COULD BE
MADE TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE AS
HEALTH PROTECTIVE AS POSSIBLE.
SALEMME DEL DOWNLOADED DEEPER.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE LOCAL
DISTRICTS CAN'T DO IT OR ARE
DOING A GOOD JOB A WHITE MALE.
IF YOU'RE GETTING COMPLAINTS I'M
ASSUMING THE LOWER DESERTING THE
SAME COMPLAINTS SO WHY TO
DUPLICATION. THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION- AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
WE WOULD LIKE SOME RESOURCES TO
MAYBE DELVE INTO THAT A LITTLE
BIT MORE- IT COULD BE THAT-
THINGS ARE NOT BEING ADDRESSED
NOT SURE WHY THAT WOULD BE THE
CASE- BUT AGAIN CARB HAS
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY THAT WE'VE
HAD FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND WE
THINK THAT THIS IS SORT OF IN
LINE WITH THOUGHT-
RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP SORT OF
IDENTIFY WHY THAT'S HAPPENING
AND WHY THAT'S THE CASE. SAID SO
JUST BE CLEAR YOU DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY PROBLEMS YOU JUST.
WANT TO DO IT. I MEAN WE SEE
THAT THERE ARE ISSUES BECAUSE
WE'RE RECEIVING COMPLAINTS- BUT
TO UNDERSTAND IN MORE DEPTH
MAYBE WHAT THOSE ISSUES ARE WE
NEED SOME ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
ARC WE HAVE CURRENT OVERSIGHT
ACTIVITIES THAT WE DO PERFORM-
NOT SPECIFIC TO A OIL AND GAS
AND SO AS A RESULT OF RECEIVING
THESE COMPLAINTS WE WOULD LIKE
TO. DELVE INTO THAT INFO WE HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THAT OKAY
BUT YOU HAVE YOU HAVE NO REASON
TO BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE JUST THE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS ARE NOT
DOING A GOOD JOB I PERSONALLY.
DON'T KNOW THAT. OKAY IT MAYBE I
CAN HAS L. L. A. IS THERE A
SITUATION WHERE. ARE THEY ARE
DISTRICTS NOT DOING. SOMETHING
THAT THEY CARP NEED TO DO. I
MEAN I DON'T THINK- EXAMPLES OF
THAT HAVE SORT OF BEEN PRESENTED
TO US- I KNOW THERE WAS. SOME
MENTION THAT AND THE BOARD'S
PRESENTATION OF KIND OF SOME
INSPECTIONS THAT THEY WERE DOING
WITH LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS THAT'S
KIND OF HIS PARTLY DRIVEN.
THAT'S HERE THEY DID FIND SOME
LEAKS BUT I GUESS IT'S UNCLEAR
TO US KIND OF. WEATHER THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN KIND OF CAUGHT
BY LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS ALONG THE
WAY ANYWAYS OR YOU KNOW HOW KIND
OF PREVALENCE OF SOME OF THOSE
PROBLEMS MIGHT BE SO I GUESS THE
SHORT ANSWER IS WE ARE. AWARE OF
A LOT OF SPECIFIC EXAMPLES WELL
LET ME ASK CARP IN THIS QUESTION
DO YOU GET COMPLAINTS. FROM
OTHER INDUSTRIES. WE DO GET
COMPLAINTS FROM OTHER
INDUSTRIES- WE DO RECEIVE A LOT
OF MOBILE SOURCE AND- PROGRAM
COMPLAINTS AS WELL WHICH WE-
INVESTIGATE- WE DO- BUT WE ALSO
RECEIVED SEVERAL COMPLAINTS
RELATED TO THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY- THE ONE THING I WILL
HIGHLIGHT AS WE HAVE GONE OUT
AND DONE JOINT INSPECTIONS WITH
DISTRICTS WE HAVE IDENTIFIED-
EXIGENCES. OF EMISSIONS
REGULATIONS FOR EXAMPLE- AND
HAVE WORKED WITH THE DISTRICT TO
RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES- BUT
SOMETIMES A YOU KNOW IT TAKES A
SORT OF. OF GOING IN THERE AND
DO NOT A VALUATION UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE ISSUE IS AND HELP TRY
TO RESOLVE IT. OKAY SO THEN- SO
AND WHEN YOU GO AND MADE SAID I
USED TO PLAY SO YOU SAY YOUR
COMPLIMENTARY SET AND IS THERE
DISTRICTS DO THEIR THING AND YOU
DO YOUR THING OR DO YOU GUYS GO
IN TOGETHER. IT SEEMS LIKE YOU
GOT TWO LAYERS KIND OF COMING IN
TOGETHER. WE DO GO IN TOGETHER
WE OFTEN DO JOINT INSPECTIONS
WITH THEIR DISTRICTS. OKAY BUT-
WHY WOULD YOU GO THERE I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS WHY WOULD YOU GO
WITH THE LOCAL DISTRICTS AND
LOCAL LOCAL AIR DISCONTENT
THEMSELVES. TO ENSURE THAT ALL
OF THE- THE- REGULATIONS ARE
BEING COMPLIED WITH- TWO PART
SO. MAYBE TAKING A STEP BACK
PART OF OUR OVERSIGHT ROLE
INCLUDES EVALUATING DISTRICT
PROGRAMS TUITION INSURE THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS- AND SO THAT'S
PART OF US GOING OUT THERE- WITH
THE DISTRICT STUFF IS TO- YOU
KNOW. SEE WHAT THEIR RULES ARE
SEE WHAT THE ISSUES ARE SORT OF
DO THAT TYPE OF EVALUATION TO
ENSURE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF AIR.
AIR QUALITY REGULATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE OKAY SO YOU BASIC
CHECKING ON THEIR DISTRICTS. I
SUPPOSE YOU COULD SAY THAT YEAH
I MEAN THAT'S PART OF OUR
OVERSIGHT ROLE. OKAY YEAH. THANK
YOU TO RETIRED PROGRAMS. WITH
YOU KNOW JUST HAVE A COULD BE
IMPROVED YOU GO TO THE OIL AND
GAS FACILITIES BUT ARE WE
MONITORING OFF SHORE WITH ALL
THE- TANKERS AND SHIPS THAT HAVE
BEEN OFF THE COAST FOR THE LAST
YEAR. IN COMPARISON TO WHAT ON
LONG DISTANCE ON LAND VERSUS THE
OCEAN BECAUSE THAT AIR HOME IT'S
COMING ON IS THERE COMPARISON OR
ANY STUDIES THAT WERE IN THE
LAST YEAR THAT HAVE BEEN UP
THERE WITH THE CAR. THAT IS A
VERY GOOD QUESTION AND I DO NOT
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT-
EVERYTHING THAT I AM SORT OF
INVOLVED IN AND AWARE OF IS MORE
OF THE- THE DRILLING THAT'S
OCCURRING ON LANDS. IS A TOPIC
THAT SORT YEAH CONCENTRATING
HERE BUT WE GOT A BIG PROBLEM
OUT HERE IN THE OCEAN. AND THAT
ERROR I MEAN THERE'S NOT A FINE
LINE WHERE DOESN'T COME ACROSS
THE BASE SO WHEN WE GET THAT
MAYBE YOU CAN. GET THAT ANSWER
FOR. SURE NOT THAT I'M THE
AUTHORITY ON THE SUBJECT LINE OF
THE PORTS OF TAKING A LOT OF
RESPONSIBILITY FOR- MAKING SURE
THAT- OF THOSE- SHIPS THAT ARE-
AWAITING BOOK- BEING UNLOADED.
ARE STAGING AND THE MANY OF THEM
ARE REMAINING OUT TO AT SEA
BEFORE THEY COME IN. SO THAT
THERE'S LESS POLLUTION AND-
DIRECTLY IN THE PORT AREAS. LET
THAT'S ONE STEPS THAT THEY'VE
TAKEN. I DON'T THINK ANY OF US
OF EXPERT BUT THAT. AIR IN THE
OCEAN. WE GET ON SHORE FLOW IT
COMES ON THE LAND OH TO BE SURE
HAVE SOME KIND OF COMPARISON AND
CHECK BECAUSE WE'RE GOING AFTER
THE- OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY. BUT
IF BECAUSE MIGHT BE OUT THE
OCEAN WITH ALL THE SHIPS RIGHT
NOW. THEY WERE BLAMING WHAT
WE'RE DOING OVER HERE SO AT OF
THE THINK WE NEED A COMPARISON.
AND A LOOK AT IT. AND WE CAN
DELIVER HERE A LOT BETTER THAN
THEY DO IN OTHER COUNTRIES
BECAUSE IF WE'RE STILL IMPORT
THE SAME AMOUNT OF IL. WE'RE
STILL USING THE SAME AMOUNT. AND
THAT THIS CRITICAL. THANK YOU
GREAT. THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION AND- OUR NEXT.
ISSUE IS ISSUE FOR WE HAVE THE
OFFICE OF STATE FIRE MARSHAL
HERE TO TALK ABOUT- FIRE AND
LIFE SAFETY DESIGNATED CAMPUS
FIRE MARSHAL PROGRAM.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING. HI
GOOD MORNING CHAIR COMMITTEE HOW
- MY NAME IS WHY CALLING AND I
AM IS STATE FARM MARSHALL I'M
EXCITED TO BE HERE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS ANY
CLARIFICATION- FROM OUR NEEDS
REQUEST TO ADD TWELVE
ADDITIONAL- PERSON NOW TO THE
FIRE AND LIFE SAFETY DIVISION-
WITH ONGOING COSTS AMOUNTING TO
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER CAMPUS PER YEAR TO SUPPORT
THE OVERSIGHT. OF AN EXISTING
AMMO YOU- WITH EACH OF THE
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES. WHY THIS
WHY NOW WAS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT THAT THE L. A. CAME UP
WITH- UNDERSTANDABLY. SO FOR A
LITTLE BACKGROUND HISTORICALLY-
THE MO YOU WHICH DELEGATED THE
AUTHORITY- OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL TO EACH CAMPUS WAS
ISSUED IN LARGE PART. DUE TO
PREVIOUS DEPUTIES OF THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE WHO WENT
TO THE UC SYSTEM EITHER BY
CHOICE OR THROUGH LAYOFFS- AT
THE- SFM. THAT STAFF WAS WELL
VERSED IN THE ENFORCEMENT ROLES
OF OUR OFFICE AS WELL AS THE CO
DEVELOPMENT PROCESSES THAT-
CREATED THE CODES THAT THEY
NEEDED TO ENFORCE- THAT GAVE
THEM A REALLY DEEP UNDERSTANDING
OF THE WISE AND WHAT FORCE. OF
THAT ENFORCEMENT JOB THAT THEY
HAD TO ENSURE THAT FIRING MY
SAFETY FOR- NOT JUST- THE STAFF-
BUT YOU KNOW FACULTY STUDENTS
AND EVEN THE FACILITY
INFRASTRUCTURES THAT WE SEE ON
ON THE UC CAMPUSES- ADDITIONALLY
HAVING THAT STAFF FROM OUR
STAFF- HAD THOSE. CLOSE CONTACT
AND PERSONAL RELATIONSHIPS
ADDITIONAL- YOU KNOW PICK UP THE
PHONE PHONE A FRIEND AND TO
ANSWER ANY OF THOSE QUESTIONS-
WHICH ALLOWED FOR US TO FEEL
PRETTY CONFIDENT AND IN THE-
CODES THAT WERE BEING ENFORCED
ON EACH OF THE CAMPUSES- NOW AND
SORT OF. BY WAY OF A DISCLAIMER-
ALL NOTE THAT OUT OF AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION DUE TO-
POTENTIAL LITIGATION CIVIL AND
POSSIBLY CRIMINAL LITIGATION WE
AREN'T ABLE TO DISCUSS IN DETAIL
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT THAT
WERE ASKED BUT- ANECDOTALLY I
WILL TALK ABOUT A- A- UNIVERSITY
ITSELF THAT- WE WERE NOTIFIED BY
AN HOUR GROWING IT DOESN'T NEED
TO CAMPUS FIRE MARSHAL THAT THEY
WERE LEAVING THAT THEY WERE THE
ONLY ONE. ON THAT FACILITY- AND
THAT THEY WOULD BE RETIRING. WE
WILL. REACH OUT WE HEARD NOTHING
FROM THE CAMPUS ITSELF- WE REACH
OUT TO THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT TO EXPLAIN- THAT WE
NEEDED SOMEBODY IN THERE- THAT
SINCE THAT AUTHORITY LIES WITH
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE
THAT IT WAS IMPERATIVE THAT IF
THEY WERE GOING TO HAVE SOMEBODY
WE HAD TO HAVE SOMEBODY IN THERE
SO WE- DID SOME CHANGING OF
STAFFING AND RE DIRECTED STAFF
TO THAT FACILITY- WHAT WAS FOUND
AT THAT FACILITY- WAS QUITE
CONCERNING WE FOUND- ISSUES
WITH- THE CONSTRUCTION. THE
OTHER- INSPECTIONS THAT WERE
DONE AND- WE'RE REALLY TROUBLED
BY THE SITUATION ESPECIALLY AS
WE PUT PUT STAFF THERE TO DO
THOSE INSPECTIONS IT BECAME MORE
AND MORE OF A CONCERN TO US THAT
THE ACTUAL AUTHORITY LIES WITHIN
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE.
WE'VE DELEGATED IT AND WE
HAVEN'T. WE DIDN'T FOLLOW UP- IT
OCCURRED TO US THAT WE REALLY
REALLY NEEDED TO STEP UP THERE
WAS HAS BEEN A- QUITE A BIT OF
FUNDS- TO THE UC SYSTEMS THAT.
AND PLANS FOR LOTS OF- NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND- DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE TO BE DONE AND OUR
OUR GREAT CONCERN WAS THAT IT
WOULDN'T BE IN ACCORDANCE WITH
OR MAY NOT BE IN ACCORDANCE
WITH. WITH THE ACTUAL CODES OF
THAT THAT ARE IN A FACT- I LOST
MY PLACE BECAUSE I WAS. DOING MY
THING HERE HAD- A CONTEST SO OUR
OFFICE- WORKS REALLY WELL
CLOSELY WITH THE- UNIVERSITY AND
CAMPUS ITSELF WE WORKS TO REVIEW
THE MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS OF
THEIR CANDIDATES THAT THEY HAD
AS A- TO HIRE FROM- WE SAT IN ON
A HIRING PANEL WITHOUT
UNIVERSITY. WE STAYED ON SITE WE
DID- LOTS OF TRAINING FOR THAT
THAT CHOSEN CANDIDATE. AND
TRYING TO BRING THEM UP TO SPEED
ON BOTH THE WAY THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL DOES THEIR JOB AND
ENFORCEMENT. AND THE CAMPUS
PROJECTS THAT WERE MID PROJECT
MID CONSTRUCTION- AND THE
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS THAT WE HAD
FOUND AND IDENTIFIED THAT NEEDED
TO BE REPAIRED- AGAIN AS THOSE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DELEGATION
WAS REALLY EXPLORED AND- THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL FELT THAT IT
WAS. IMPORTANT THAT WE REACH OUT
WITH THE SPRING FINANCE WATER
AND MAKE THIS REQUEST AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE- THERE ARE CURRENTLY-
ACCORDING TO OUR RECORDS THERE
ARE ONLY TWENTY EIGHT CAN'T
DESIGNATE A CAMPUS FIRE MARSHALS
FROM OUR OFFICE THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR FIRE AND LIFE
SAFETY ASPECTS ON ALL PROPERTIES
OWNED OR LEASED BY THE UC'S- SO
ANECDOTALLY IN THIS GROUP- THAT
IS FOR DESIGNATED CAMPUS FIRE
MARSHALS FOR. ALL OF BERKELEY-
TO FOR ALL OF UCLA AND TO FOR
UCSF AND UCSF MED CENTER- IT.
NOT NEARLY ENOUGH- THERE THERE'S
A DISPARITY IN REGARDS TO THE
WORKLOAD OR DISPLAY IT'S A
DISPROPORTIONATE WORKLOAD
COMPARED TO THE NUMBERS THAT WE
HAVE ON SITE- WE ARE ALSO
UNAWARE SINCE THESE DESIGNATED
CAMPUS FIRE MARSHAL'S REPORT TO
THE SPECIFIC UNIVERSITIES WE ARE
UNAWARE AS TO WHAT OTHER DUTIES
HAVE BEEN ASSIGNED TO THESE
PEOPLE THROUGH THEIR UC CHAIN OF
COMMAND- SO AGAIN MORE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE- LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE AND THEN. OBVIOUSLY THEY
CAN BE DIRECTED THROUGH THEIR
CHAIN OF COMMAND ANNUALLY WE DO
RESERVE RECEIVE A REPORT FROM
THE- THE OFFICE OF THE UC OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT IT CONSISTS OF
A NUMBER OF- INSPECTIONS WHETHER
IT'S- CALIFORNIA CODE OF
REGULATIONS TITLE NINETEEN OR
TITLE TWENTY FOUR INSPECTIONS
ARE CONDUCTED- GOOD STEWARDSHIP
WOULD DICTATE THAT WE- THAT THE
OFFICE OF STATE FIRE MARSHAL
WOULD BE ABLE TO REVIEW THAT
LIST AND FOLLOW UP- TO BE SURE
THAT THOSE. AT JUST SPOT
INSPECTIONS NOT DUPLICATIVE
SERVICES BUT SPOT INSPECTIONS
THAT ARE AUTHORITY IS BEING-
CONDUCTED APPROPRIATELY- YOU FOR
EVERYTHING FROM CODE COMPLIANCE
TO CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS OR-
FOLLOWING UP ON DEFICIENCY
NOTICES THAT HAVE BEEN ISSUED
WHETHER THOSE THINGS HAVE BEEN
CORRECTED- MUCH LIKE ANY
DELEGATION WHETHER IT'S THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE
DELEGATING- ARE THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL HIMSELF DELEGATING ME TO
SPEAK TO YOU- ON THIS ISSUE- OR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
ACCESS INFORMATION WHICH WE USE
H. CHI USED TO BE OCCUPIED- WHO
HOLDS THE RESPONSIBILITY AND
DELEGATES TO THE UC MEDICAL
CENTERS- TO MONITOR THEIR
CONSTRUCTION RENOVATIONS AND
SAFETY AT HOSPITALS AND SKILLED
NURSING. FACILITIES THE ULTIMATE
RESPONSIBILITY IS THE STATE FARM
MARSHALL OR- THE DIRECTOR H. CHI
- ONE OF MY GO TO STATEMENTS IS
IT'S OKAY TO BE WRONG IT'S NOT
OKAY TO STAY WRONG SO THIS IS
OUR ATTEMPT TO RESET THIS IMHO.
WITH A HIGHER DEGREE OF
OVERSIGHT AND- REALLY GETTING
HAVING STAFF TO GET TO THOSE
CAMPUSES MAKE THOSE CMPUS
RELATIONSHIPS AND BE ABLE TO-
HAVE THAT WORKING RELATIONSHIP
SO THAT WE CAN SOLVE- PROBLEMS
OR ISSUES TOGETHER INSTEAD OF IN
THOSE SILOS THAT THAT ARE ARE
FREQUENTLY AND ARE CURRENTLY
CREATED- AGAIN THIS ISN'T A
DUPLICATE OF PROGRAM BUT AN
OVERSIGHT PROGRAM THAT IS NEEDED
TO PROTECT OUR AUTHORITY- OF
THAT HAS BEEN DELEGATED TO THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S. UNDERSTAND
HELEN AND THE ISSUES THAT SHE'S
WRITTEN ON- BUT- AT THIS POINT
THERE'S SO MANY SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES- THAT WE REALLY REALLY-
ARE REQUESTING YOUR SUPPORT- AND
OVERTURNING THE. TO PUSH THIS
OUT FOR MAYBE ANOTHER B. C. P.
SEASON. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
THAT PRESENTATION- WHEN WE
TURNED OUT TO LA- FOR. THEIR
PERSPECTIVE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS HAILING CHRISTINE
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
TODAY- SO WE'RE RECOMMENDING
REJECTING THE PROPOSAL-
BASICALLY WE DIDN'T FEEL THAT
THE FIRE MARSHALL HAD ADEQUATELY
SUBSTANTIATED THE JUSTIFICATION
AT THIS POINT- AND THERE ARE A
COUPLE REASONS- ONE WE DIDN'T
FEEL THAT WE GOT SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE WHEN WE WERE- DOING A
REVIEW TO ADEQUATELY JUSTIFY-
REALLY THAT YOU. SEE HASN'T
BEEN- CONDUCTING SUFFICIENT
ENFORCEMENT- A BUILDING
STANDARDS IN THEIR FACILITIES
ARE CURRENTLY AS WAS MENTIONED
AND THIS IS ACTUALLY OUR YOU'RE
GETTING IS THAT YOU SEE IT
BASICALLY HAD THIS DELEGATED
AUTHORITY FOR SOMETIME SINCE
EVER SINCE ROUGHLY NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR- SO WE DIDN'T HAVE
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO BE ABLE
TO ASCERTAIN WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY WERE ADEQUATELY OVERSEEING
THAT THE- THOSE FACILITIES
THEMSELVES I'M OR WHETHER. IN
THE- RIGHT SO MAYBE THE POPULAR
DAY HERE THE CAPITAL. OR WHAT
THE BEST SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM
WOULD BE TO ESTABLISH A NEW UNIT
WITH AND THE FIRE MARSHAL OR
WHETHER THERE MIGHT BE OTHER
WAYS TO ADDRESS THESE- THESE
CONCERNS SHOULD THEY BE- SHOULD
THEY SHOULD THEY HAVE MERIT ON
THE OTHER THING WE WANT TO NOTE
IS THAT- IN OUR CONVERSATIONS
AND- CORRESPONDENCE WITH YOU SEE
THEY RAISED SOME SOME
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL THEY DIDN'T FEEL LIKE
IT WAS WARRANTED. ON US THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THAT- THAT THEY
WEREN'T THEY WEREN'T WHERE THIS
PROPOSAL IS COMING FORWARD AND
THEY DID HAVE SOME CONCERNS SO
AGAIN- YOU KNOW IT I THINK IT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
RECOMMENDING REJECTING A
PROPOSAL AND THEN SHOULD THE
ADMINISTRATION FEEL LIKE THIS IS
YOU KNOW REALLY A CRITICAL ISSUE
COME BACK IN JANUARY THAT'LL
GIVE EVERYONE A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME. YEAH APRIL IT'S JUST SUCH
A- COMPRESSED A PERIOD OF TIME
FOR THE LEGISLATORS LATE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THIS-
TALK TO YOU SEE REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE DYNAMICS OF THIS
ISSUE AND SO- OUR PERSPECTIVE IS
THAT YOU KNOW IF THIS IS
CONSIDERED IN JANUARY IT'LL GIVE
US MORE TIME FOR THE FIRE
MARSHAL TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IT WILL
GIVE SOME MORE TIME FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
YOU SEE- TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THIS ISSUE AND WHETHER THIS IS
THE BEST SOLUTION. THE HAPPY TO
TAKE. THANK YOU- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE STEVEN BANDS WITH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE THANK YOU
STRUCTURE- YES WILL REITERATE
THAT YOU KNOW AGAIN THIS ISN'T
ABOUT REDUNDANCY- THE AT THE UC
DOES IT CAMPUS FIRE MARSHALS
WILL CONTINUE TO DO PLAN REVIEW
THE CONTINUE TO CONSTRUCTION
SECTION THE CONTINUED TO THEIR
BUILDING INSPECTIONS THIS IS
ABOUT HAVING APPROPRIATE AND
PRUDENT INDEPENDENT OBJECTIVE
OVERIGHT OTHERS THOUGHT IT'S
BEEN DELEGATED- I THINK GIVEN
THE- PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS. THAT ARE AT
STAKE THAT HAVING APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT IS IMPORTANT- THANK AS
CHIEF COLLINS POINTED OUT. YOU
EAT CAN'T GO THROUGH NECESSARILY
INTO A LAUNDRY LIST OF
EVERYTHING THAT'S WRONG EVERY
CAMPUS BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW
UNTIL YOU'RE THERE AND YOU FIND
OUT THAT'S WHAT OVERSIGHT IS
REALLY ABOUT. I THINK IT'S JUST
BECAUSE WHEN IT OUT AS THEY
BECAME AWARE THAT I NEED TO GO
INTO SOME MORE FINDING OUT IS
NEEDED AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THIS PROPOSAL IS ABOUT. IS
GETTING IN. SEEING WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND MAKING SURE THAT
THAT IN A FIRE AND PANIC SAFETY
CODE COMPLIANCE IS HAPPENING IN
A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE- THE
STUDENTS AND STAFF AND FACULTY.
THAT IS BETTER ON THE CAMPUSES.
WE FEEL THAT THE YOU KNOW A
PROPOSAL DOESN'T PLACE AN UNDUE
UNDUE BURDEN ON ANY CAMPUS WHEN
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THE-
POTENTIAL PROPORTIONAL IMPACT IS
TO ANYONE CAMPUS IT SEEMS
RELATIVELY MODERATE. MODEST AND
I ALSO JUST POINT OUT THAT THE
STATE FARM MARSHALL'S OFFICE
BILLS AN HOURLY RATE AND SO ANY
CAMPUS THAT'S IN GOOD WORKING
ORDER IN GOOD SHAPE IS NOT GOING
TO GET BILL VERY MUCH YOU KNOW
THE BUILDING WILL ONLY REALLY
HAPPEN. IF THERE'S ISSUES THAT
HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED- SO WITH WE
FEEL THIS PROPOSAL IS MODEST AND
IT'S APPROPRIATE. AND IT HELPS
HIM- FILL A GAP IN SOME
IMPORTANT HEALTH AND SAFETY.
COMPLIANCE SO THE IDEA THAT THIS
IS AN INTERESTING JURISDICTIONAL
ISSUE WE HAVE THE- UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY- PROTECTED IN
MANY WAYS AS AN INDEPENDENT. TO
AGENCY AN INDEPENDENT- ENTITY IN
THE STATE- AND YET THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL IS. CHARGED WITH.
OVERSEEING THESE ASPECTS OF
SAFETY ON CAMPUS WHY WHY WOULD
WE NOT EXPECT. THE UC. TWO A
COVER THE COST OF THE- BOTTOM.
OF THAT OVERSIGHT INSPECTION.
THE UC WOULD COVER THE COSTS OF
THE DIVISION OF- FIRE LIFE
SAFETY WAS NOT STATE FARM
MARSHALL IS FUNDED ON A
REIMBURSEMENT BASIS. SO THEY
WITH THE CAMPUSES WOULD YOU SEE
WOULD BE BILLED AND REIMBURSED.
AFTER THE THREE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS- WOULD BE
REIMBURSABLE BY THE UNIVERSITY
CORRECT. I SEE. OKAY- TUCHET
COLLINS- MAYBE YOU'D LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE ALEJO'S- STATED CONCERNS-
AND- IT THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS- AND MAYBE TO WORK THE
CITY REMARKS ALSO YOU IDENTIFIED
I THINK EIGHT INDIVIDUALS FOR
THEM AT- AT CAL- A TO A C. L. A.
AND THEN. TO AT THE REST OF THE
CAMPUS- MAYBE WAS UCSF AND WHEN
OTHER CAMPUS WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
THE OTHER CAMPUSES- IF YOU'VE
GOT NOT YOU BUT IF THERE ARE
FOUR PEOPLE- INSPECTORS OUT AT
CAL. DECIDES THAT CAMPUS ISN'T
THAT MUCH DIFFERENT FROM UCLA
AND YOU ONLY HAVE TO THEIR- IT
SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S AN IMBALANCE
AND THAT THE- COVERAGE WE WOULD
NEED DOESN'T EXIST RIGHT NOW-
YES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY- AS WE HAD DISCUSSED
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT IN REGARDS TO-
THIS BUDGET CHANGE PROPELLER
THIS REQUEST AND- DISCUSS WITH
THEM THOSE ISSUES IN PARTICULAR
THE DISPARITY IN OF NUMBER OF-
DESIGNATED CAMPUS FIRE MARSHALS.
AT THE DIFFERENT FACILITIES NOW
IT. IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW AGAIN
THAT THE DESIGNATED CAMPUS FIRE
MARSHALS WORK FOR THE SPECIFIC
FACILITY SO THAT EACH EACH
CAMPUS CAN HIRE AS MANY OR AS
FEW AS THEY CHOOSE- THERE IS NOT
A MINIMUM NUMBER. MAY I
INTERRUPT AND JUST GAS THAT THAT
IS THROUGH AUTHORITY THAT IS
DELEGATED FROM THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL'S OFFICE IS THAT CORRECT
THAT'S CORRECT THE- WELL AND THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE. I HATE
DOING THIS WITHOUT IT IN FRONT
OF ME- I BELIEVE IT ALLOWS US TO
DELEGATE- A DESIGNATED CAMPUS
FIRE MARSHAL TO THE FACILITY. SO
THAT'S THAT'S WHERE IT COMES
FROM. AND SOMEHOW ALONG THE WAY
IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S BEEN A
BREAK DOWN AND SORT OF THE FLOW
OF INFORMATION AND OVERSIGHT AND
COMMUNICATION AND PERHAPS
ACCOUNTABILITY BETWEEN- THE UC
AND THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
THAT'S CORRECT- WE DID START
HAVING DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT- TO TRY TO- THEY HAVE
TAKEN ON THE ROLE- TO TRY TO
ADMINISTER THAT INFORMATION FROM
EACH OF THE CAMPUSES IN ONE
PLACE. BUT THE DESIGNATION IS
SPECIFIC TO THOSE CAMPUSES. IS
THERE A- I I'M- AWARE OF- A
SHORTAGE OF- FIREFIGHTERS AND
PARAMEDICS IN THE STATE IS MY
SON'S A FIREFIGHTER PARAMEDIC
AND HE REPORTS AND MAKE. BUT BUT
I KNOW THAT THERE'S A SHORTAGE
PARTLY BECAUSE OF- OF
RETIREMENTS IS THAT PART OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE ALSO THAT-
RETIREMENT CIRQUE CELEBRATING.
AS THEY ARE IN MANY SECTORS OF
THE ECONOMY AND- POSITIONS ARE
NOT BEING FILLED THIS QUICKLY
THAT KIND OF THING. YES THAT IS
THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT THAT WE
HAVE AND IT'S ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT LED US HERE WAS- THROUGH
ATTRITION AT BOTH THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL'S OFFICE AS WELL AS AT
THE DESIGNATED CAMPUS FIRE
MARSHAL UP ALL THOSE CONNECTIONS
THAT PEOPLE HAD. JUST SORT OF-
DEVOLVED- AWAY AND WHICH YOU
KNOW SOMEBODY NEW COMES IN AND
EVERYONE IS BUSY- SO THE TIME TO
MAKE THOSE CONNECTIONS I THINK
ARE HARDER- I THINK WE'RE COMING
OUT OF THAT NOW- AS WE GET TO
SEE EACH OTHER IN PERSON. THAT I
THINK THAT THERE IS AN ABSOLUTE
INTEREST FOR PEOPLE TO MEET NEW
PEOPLE AND ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY
SEE NEW PEOPLE AND DEVELOP THOSE
CONNECTIONS AND RELATIONSHIPS
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'D LIKE TO SEE
DONE- EIGHT THERE ARE DEFINITE
BENEFITS TO THIS PROGRAM. BY IT
THERE THERE IS I'M NOT TRYING
I'M NOT HERE TRYING TO SAY THAT
THIS PROGRAM IS INEFFECTIVE OR-
OR DOESN'T NECESSARILY WORK BUT
WE JUST DON'T KNOW. AND WHERE
THAT AUTHORITY IT ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE LOOK AT PLACES THAT HAVE
YOU KNOW PEOPLE SEND THEIR
CHILDREN AND- THE- THOSE
CAMPUSES ARE JUST SUCH HUBS OF
ACTIVITY AND INFORMATION AND-
GATHERINGS AND EDUCATION THAT IT
WOULD JUST BE REALLY GREAT TO
KNOW FOR SURE THAT THEY WERE
CONSTRUCTED APPROPRIATELY SO-
ARE YOU GIVING THOUGHT TO- AT-
AFTER YOU- TRANSITION TO THESE
NEW POSITIONS AND- BEGIN TO
LEARN. MORE ABOUT THE- HOW THE
PROGRAM IS WORKING WHAT'S GOING
ON YOU GIVING THOUGHT TO THE
POSSIBILITY OF RESTRUCTURING-
THE PROGRAM HOW LONG HOW LONG IS
THIS- DELEGATION OF AUTHORITY
BEEN AND- IT CAME IN IN. WAS IT
A BILL 202-120-0022 THOUSAND AND
TEN POINT FORMALLY OKAY SO PRIOR
TO THAT REJECTED YEAH IT AND
THERE HAD BEEN THE ELLIE- IS
CORRECT THAT THERE HAD BEEN AN
INFORMAL- DELEGATION AT THAT
TIME IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN THE
FIRE MARSHAL SAID WE SHOULD
PROBABLY FROM THIS THING UP AND
DID IT FORMALLY. THROUGH THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE- SO EAT
YEAH IT WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY NICE
TO BE ABLE TO REALLY YOU. REALLY
LOOK AT THESE DELEGATIONS AND
HOW WE DO THEM- COMING UP THE CS
. ALSO HAVE THAT ABILITY- FOR US
TO DELEGATE THAT RESPONSIBILITY
WE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO-
WE'VE STARTED AN AMMO YOU WITH
THEM IT IS STRUCTURED VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THE THAN THE UC
AMONG YOU- AND- SO RESTRUCTURING
IS DEFINITELY- IN OUR THOUGHT
PROCESS. ON HOW TO MAKE THIS
BETTER AND HOW TO MAKE IT MORE
STREAMLINED. GROUP ONE THANK YOU
. THIS IS LEVEL I'LL GO AHEAD
AND ASK A COUPLE OF THEM SO YOU
HAVE A CAMPUS FIRE MARSHAL IN
THE NEW HAVE CAL FIRE MARSHAL
CHECKING ON THE CAMPUS. MARSHALL
WHAT IS THE OVERLAY YOU DON'T
BELIEVE WHAT THE CAMPUS FIRE
MARSHALS AND- YOUR CHECK IN
SOMETHING DIFFERENT THAT THEY'RE
NOT CHECKING. WELL IT WOULD BE
MORE OF AN OVERSIGHT IS THE
THOUGHT PROCESS- REVIEWING THEIR
INSPECTIONS MAY BE GOING TO A
BUILDING THAT'S UNDER
CONSTRUCTION AND TAKING A LOOK
TO BE SURE THAT THAT THINGS
WEREN'T WEREN'T MESSED- THERE IS
SO. CONSTRUCTION INSPECTIONS IS
SO INTRICATE THAT- IF YOU IF YOU
MISS ONE- IF YOU PUT A FIRE
DAMPER INSTEAD OF A SMOKE FIRE
DAMPER WHICH IS REQUIRED BY
STATE REGULATIONS THAT COULD END
UP COSTING QUITE A BIT DOWN THE
ROAD SO- TRYING TO BE SURE THAT
WE ARE SPENDING MORE MONEY DOWN
THE ROAD- OR THAT THE FACILITY
IS AND SPENDING MORE MONEY DOWN
THE ROAD THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO- IS. IS NEVER SHOULD NEVER BE
PAINFUL- FINDING A MISTAKE
EARLIER THAN LATER IS OFTEN THIS
IS FOR DENNIS NEW CONSTRUCTION
THAT. WOULD BE THROUGHOUT TO- GO
THROUGH AND BE SURE EVEN THAT- A
LOT OF TIMES WHAT HAPPENS ON
CAMPUSES IS YOU HAVE ONE
INSTRUCTOR THAT WANTS TO DO ONE
THING. THEY LEAVE THE NEXT'S
INSTRUCTOR COMES IN- PROFESSOR
COMES IN AND THEY WANT TO
REARRANGE- ALL ROOM AND MAYBE
THEY WANT THEY HAVE THEIR OWN-
EQUIPMENT THAT COMES IN WELL
MAYBE IT BLOCKS AN EXIT. SO
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE REVIEWED TO BE
SURE THAT YOU ARE MAINTAINING
THAT EXITING FOR EVERYBODY
THAT'S USING THAT FACILITY. SO
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF SPOT
CHECKS THAT ARE DONE THERE ARE-
INSPECTIONS THAT ARE DONE ON ALL
THE HIGH RISES- I WAS REVIEWING
SOME OF THEM YESTERDAY THERE
ARE. DEFICIENCIES THAT WERE
NOTED BY THE DESIGNATED CAMPUS
FIRE MARSHALS AND SO IN. IN MY
VIEW OF THIS PROGRAM IT WOULD
BE- SOMEONE FROM OUR OFFICE
GOING BACK TO BE SURE THAT THOSE
ISSUES HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED.
BECAUSE IF THEY ARE ADDRESSED
AND ARE BEING IGNORED THEN- WE
NEED TO GO THROUGH THAT
ENFORCEMENT ASPECT. THAT
POTENTIALLY MAY NOT BE A
COMFORTABLE PLACE FIRST TO HIM
FOR AN EMPLOYEE TO ENFORCE
AGAINST THEIR EMPLOYER. WHO SAY
THAT CHECKS OUT NOW. THE CARD
THREE POINT TWO MILLION BECAUSE
LAST YEAR DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
REQUEST WAS- HURT- DOLLAR WISE
AND HOW MUCH WAS REIMBURSED. SO
IS IT BEEN TEN YEARS I THINK WAS
AN OUTLOOK OUT HERE. BUT WE- WE
HAVEN'T STARTED THIS PROGRAM
YET. THIS OVERSIGHT PROGRAM IS
THAT WHICH I MAY BE WAS THAT
TODAY OKAY SO YOUIT'LL BE
OFFERING NO NOTHING SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TEN WHAT THE PROGRAM
WAS STARTED THERE'S NOT BEEN NO
OVERSIGHT AND- SO THEY'VE DONE
SOME SOME REDIRECTION OF STAFF
IS THE- IN. THE CHIEF MENTIONED
A PARTICULAR CAMPUS THAT YOU
KNOW HAD THERE DID DOESN'T
CAMPUS FIRE MARSHAL. LEAVE ASIDE
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING ON HOW MANY HOURS WERE
SPENT AT THAT CAMPUS YOU KNOW I
DIDN'T THINK TO BRING THAT THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN AMAZING TO BRING
BUT I DIDN'T I CAN CERTAINLY GET
BACK TO YOU I WAS JUST SICK AND
I'M- I'M JUST TRYING TO CHECK
FOR. CALIFORNIA LOVE WHAT YOU
GUYS ARE DOING AND SO ON TO WORK
BUT CHECKS AND BALANCES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS CHECKS AND
BALANCES AND WE'RE JUST NOT. WE
PAT EACH OTHER ON THE BACK GOING
THROUGH WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT NO ONE EVER LOSES HER LIFE
AND ONE OF THESE FIRES AND
THAT'S THE CRITICAL PART ABOUT
THIS. CORRECT OKAY ABSOLUTE.
WELL SO I THINK THE ONLY-
ADDITIONAL COMMENT I WOULD MAKE
IS THAT I THINK IT'S- IMPORTANT
THAT- WHAT YOU'RE DOING ISN'T
DUPLICATING WHAT'S ALREADY
HAPPENING IT IS MORE IN THE
NATURE OF OVERSEEING WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE- ON THE
CAMPUSES UNDERSTANDING. THAT
THERE'S PROBABLY SOME
SIGNIFICANT GRAY AREA THERE
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE GOING IN THE
EXAMPLE THAT YOU GAVE OF THE
CHIMNEY. THING THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT- THAT'S GOING TO
BE INSPECTED PRESUMABLY BY THE
ON CAMPUS FIRE MARSHAL AND THEN
IT MAY BE. YOU KNOW THERE MAY BE
A HUNDRED THINGS LIKE THAT THAT
AND THE OVERSIGHT IS ONLY GOING
TO PROBABLY LOOK AT A SUBSET OF
THOSE THINGS BUT IT MIGHT CROSS
OVER SO MIGHT GET A DOUBLE
CHECK. BUT. I DON'T THINK WE
NEED AND MAYBE YOU CAN TELL ME
IF I'M RIGHT OR WRONG ON THIS I
DON'T THINK THAT WE NEED- TWO
IDENTICAL LAYERS OF FIRE
MARSHALS- AT EAST EAST CAMPUS
THE THING THAT- IT'S BEEN
DETERMINED TO BE MISSING. IS
THE- CONSISTENT OVERSIGHT ROLE
OF THE- STATE FARM MARSHAL'S
OFFICE CORRECT SO IF. IF WE
WANTED TO BE DUPLICATIVE THERE
WOULD BE WAY MORE THAN TWELVE.
POSITIONS ASKED IN THIS- SAYS
LIKE THEY'RE DOING IT WITH EIGHT
. WELL THAT'S JUST FOR THE THREE
CAMPUSES THEY'RE DOING IT WITH A
TOTAL OF TWENTY EIGHT STATEWIDE
OKAY OKAY I MISSED THAT. WHO IS
THAT THAT. THAT THAT BRINGS ME A
LOT MORE COMFORT BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THAT THERE IT SOUNDED
LIKE- WHAT I WAS HEARING WAS
THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY A
SHORTFALL OF- INDIVIDUALS- OKAY
. SO I THINK THAT PROBABLY-
BRINGS US TO CLOSE ON THIS ITEM
AND THAT IS THE LAST- ITEM ON
OUR AGENDA FOR DISCUSSION. WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO-
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
MEMBERS ON THE NON DISCUSSION
ITEMS- THIS DEBATE HERE BUT MAN
I DON'T HAVE ANY. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON- DISCUSSION ITEMS
SO- WILL DISPENSE WITH THAT-
PART OF OUR AGENDA AND MOVE ON
TO PUBLIC COMMENT- AND AS I SAID
EARLIER EVERYONE WILL HAVE- UP
TO ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK. WE'LL
START WITH THOSE IN THE ROOM AND
THEN OPEN THE PHONE LINES- FOR
THOSE OF YOU LISTENING AND IF
YOU WANT TO CALL IN THE NUMBERS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
ONE TWO SEVEN. AND WILL BEGIN
NOW WITH PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
ROOM WELCOME. THANK YOU A GOOD
MORNING- MICROBES HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE GLASS PACKAGING USED TO
WHICH IS THE- TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR GLASS CONTAINER
MANUFACTURERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
IN THE NATION FOR THAT MATTER-
ON THE ON THE GOVERNOR'S- BOTTLE
BILL PROPOSAL ON. WE SUPPORT WE
WERE SUPPORTIVE AND ENCOURAGED%
BY THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN THE
PROGRAM WE THINK THAT'S A GOOD
THING- WE WANT TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND CARRY CYCLE ON
ON. THE OTHER DETAILS WITH WE
THINK THAT THE MONEY SHOULD BE
PROBABLY REALLOCATED TO PUT MORE
EMPHASIS ON THAT BY BACK
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR CONSUMER
CONVENIENCE- WE OPPOSE THE
DOUBLE REDEMPTION IDEA- WE THINK
THERE ARE SOME PRACTICAL AND
SOME PRACTICAL CONCERNS AND
THINGS THAT- YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND- AND MISTERS- SOMEONE SMITH
BROUGHT UP ON. ON THE RV ENDS
THAT WE THINK THE REVERSE
VENDING MACHINES WILL. SOUND
GREAT BUT YOU YOU NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S A RECYCLING- CENTER
BACKING THEM THAT ARE SUPPORTING
THEM OTHERWISE IT JUST WON'T
WORK. AND WE THINK THE MOBILE
RECYCLING SOUNDS PROMISING BUT I
THINK IT AT THE L. A. O. NOTED-
THAT THE PILOTS HAVEN'T PROVEN
THEMSELVES YET AND WE IT SO IT'S
A LOT OF MONEY FOR SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT SHOWN- STRUCK SHOWN-
ABILITY TO WORK. BUT THE BAG
DROPS- THE BACKDROP PROGRAMS
HAVE WORKED IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AND WE THINK THOSE
ARE THAT'S A GOOD THAT'S A GOOD
INVESTMENT. AND ON THE QUALITY
INCENTIVE PAYMENT. I'M AS IT
APPLIES THE GLASS SPECIFICALLY
WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS ON
THE QUALITY INCENTIVE PAYMENT
HOW IT- HOW HOW IT WOULD BE USED
IN IN PRACTICE AND- WE WILL WANT
TO ENSURE IT DOESN'T. JUST
CONTINUE TO REWARD POOR QUALITY-
COLLECTION AND MOVEMENT FROM THE
MURPH AND WITH THEIR THEIR STIR
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE DONE HERE
WE WANT. TO WORK WITH YOU ON IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING KYLE JONES WITH
COMMUNITY Y. CENTER AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF CLEAN WATER ACTION
JUST WANTED TO SUPPORT- THE
SEVEN NEW POSITIONS FOR SIGMA AT
THE WATER BOARD. WHICH IS REYES
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER OR NOT
SEVEN POSITIONS WILL BE ENOUGH
THE BOARD NOTED THAT TWELVE
BASES ARE GOING. POTENTIALLY A
PROBATIONARY STATUS THAT
INCLUDES THIRTY FOUR PLANTS. AND
SO WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S ENOUGH RESOURCES IN
PLACE TO GET THOSE- MOVED
QUICKLY AND AT FOR THAT REASON
WE ALSO BELIEVE THE SEQUEL
EXEMPTION IS APPROPRIATE SINCE A
SIMILAR EXEMPTION WAS AFFORDED.
TO LOCAL AGENCIES AS THEY
DEVELOP THOSE PLANS- THE FINANCE
LETTER NOT SET UP TO THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED BESTING WELLS COULD GO
TRY THIS YEAR ALONE AND IF WE
HAVE ANOTHER YEAR OF DROUGHT.
THAT COULD GET EVEN WORSE AND SO
WE HOPE THESE PLANS WILL BE IN
PLACE NEXT YEAR SO WE CAN ENSURE
THAT DRINKING WATER MITIGATION
PROGRAMS AND THE LIKE. ARE IN
PLACE TO ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ANTHONY MILLION N BEHALF OF THE
PLASTIC RECYCLING CORPORATION IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE AMERICAN
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION. I WE WANT
TO START BY THANKING THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS ADMINISTRATION.
FOR PRACTICALLY ENGAGING
PROVIDING A FRAMEWORK. TO ASSIST
THE CONTAINER RECYCLING BEVERAGE
PROGRAM- IN THE PROPOSED PCP.
HOWEVER IS CURRENTLY PROPOSE
THAT WE BELIEVE THERE IS ROOM
FOR IMPROVEMENT IN THE PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE ONE TIME
SPENDING OF THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR CREDIT- FOR LIMITED TAKE
BACK A BEVERAGE CONTAINERS- WE
BELIEVE THAT RE PRIORITIZING
THINGS FUNDS- TO INVEST IN THE
EXISTING TAKE BACK CENTERS THE
NEW CERTIFIED RECYCLING CENTERS
IN THE PROPOSAL. NEW PROCESSORS
AND ADDITIONAL METHODS FOR
COLLECTION- ARE BETTER
INVESTMENTS AND WILL HAVE A LONG
TERM IMPACT ON THE RECYCLING
SYSTEM- WE KNOW THAT THESE TYPES
OF INVESTMENTS IN THE PAST. I'VE
HELP RICK- INCREASE THE STATE'S
RECYCLING RATE. PROVIDE CLEAN
MATERIALS TO MEET THE NEW
MANDATE. FOR MANDATORY. CONTENT
AND THEN ALSO PROVIDE A CIRCULAR
ECONOMY WILL STRENGTHEN THAT.
WHICH IS A PART OF THE PROPOSAL.
AND THEN FINALLY. WE WOULD LIKE
TO MENTION THAT THERE ARE SOME
POLICY CHANGE THAT WE BELIEVE.
WOULD GO HAND IN HAND. WITH THE
B. C. P. TO HELP THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROPOSAL
TO SHARE THE SHOULD BE TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION. A FEW OF
THOSE ARE FLEXIBLE STAFFING
HOURS. HOURSOF OPERATION
ELECTRONIC PAYMENTS TO
CONSUMERS. EDUCATION ONGOING
MAINTENANCE AND- CISTICOLIDAE
XIN METHOD. FOR MATERIALS WHEN
USING THE AUTOMATED RECYCLING
MACHINES. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR WORK WITH YOU
GUYS IS THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR BEING SO THOROUGH. I
EXPECT NOTHING LESS FROM- WELL
TRAINED INDIVIDUALS LIKE
YOURSELF. ALSO NOTE. GREG HER ON
BEHALF OF THE CAN MANUFACTURERS
INSTITUTE- REPRESENTING THE
MAKERS OF THE MOST RECYCLED AND
RECYCLABLE CONTAINER AVAILABLE-
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BROUGHT FORTH A
PROPOSAL- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE CRV AND HAVE ENCOURAGE OTHER
STATES TO ADOPT SIMILAR PROGRAMS
TO INCREASE THE RECYCLING RATE
NATIONWIDE BUT I'D LIKE TO ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH SOME OF THOSE
THAT ANTHONY JUST MADE WE
ACTUALLY WE DO HAVE SOME VERY.
SIMILAR CONCERNS THROUGHOUT THE
PROPOSAL FUNDAMENTALLY EACH
PROPOSAL NEEDS TO BE EVALUATED
AGAINST ITS ABILITY TO INCREASE
CONSUMER CONVENIENCE. AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR REDEMPTION AND
IMPROVE MATERIAL QUALITY WERE
STARVING FOR GETTING MATERIAL
BACK RIGHT NOW IN THE INDUSTRY.
THE PANDEMIC PRETTY UNIQUE
SITUATION THE BUILT UP THE
RESERVE BUT WE NEED TO BE VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE SPEND THAT RESERVE TIM MAKE
LASTING IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
PROGRAM THAT INCREASES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONSUMERS. SO
WE APPRECIATE YOU KEEPING THE
ITEM OPEN SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN THAT
APARTMENT AND FIND SOME
FUNDAMENTAL THINGS THAT WILL
REALLY IMPROVE THE SYSTEM FOR
CONSUMERS. AND NOT PUT MONEY OUT
JUST IN A ONE TIME THING WHERE
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
WOULDN'T EVEN BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BURST ON CAP
KEY MCCUE CAP CAN ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF STRATEGIC MATERIALS
THE LARGEST CLASS PROCESSOR IN
THE STATE NATION. ARE WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION COMING FORWARD
WITH A PROPOSAL TO UTILIZE SOME
OF THESE FUNDS ARE FOR
INCREASING RECYCLING. HOW WE
SHARE THE COMMENTS OF SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES AROUND WANTING TO
FOCUS SOME OF THE SPENDING. ON A
RECYCLING CENTERS ARE OVER AND
ABOVE SOME OF THE OTHER OPTIONS
I PARTICULARLY FOR GLASS. I SOME
OF THE OPTIONS TO PRESENT
CHALLENGES ARE WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND OUR VIA MACHINES MAY
BE WORKABLE FOR SOME OTHER
MATERIAL TYPES. FIVE SMI DOES
HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT. THE FACT
THAT MANY OF THOSE MATURE AT
THOSE EQUIPMENT. I DO CRUSH THAT
GLASS OUT WHICH RESULTS IN YIELD
LOSS OF SOME OF THE FEINSTEIN
SO. THAT WHILE WE STRONGLY YOU
KNOW SUPPORT RECYCLING THAT IS A
CONCERN JUST IN TERMS OF
RELIANCE ON RPM'S FOR GLASS
SPECIFICALLY. HOW WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE COMMENTS MADE ABOUT
HELPING TO ENSURE. A BETTER
QUALITY CERTAINLY- STRATEGIC
MATERIALS IS A KEY- YOU KNOW
ENTITY AND IN DOING THAT HELPING
TO CLEAN AND COLOR SORT THAT
CLASS- FOR RE PURPOSING INTO NEW
EYEGLASS PACKAGING. AND OVERALL
ALLOW WE WOULD CERTAINLY SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT SOME ADDITIONAL REFORMS TO
HELP STRENGTHEN THE PROGRAM. A
RECYCLING REDEMPTION AND I
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
CLASS AND IN THE CONTEXT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT INCLUDING
WINE AND SPIRITS. UNDER THE
PROGRAM FOR SB TEN THIRTEEN
THOSE ARE CONVENIENT RECYCLING
CENTER OPTIONS ARE GOING TO BE
MISSION CRITICAL TO ENSURE A
COLLECTION HAPPENED SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN LOUIS BROWN WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
WOULD LIKE TO LINE- SOME OF OUR-
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF. PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS DO APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION COMING FORWARD
WITH THE PROPOSALS THAT WE CAN
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT.
HOW THE BOTTLE BILL OTHER
RESERVISTS JUST DEFINITELY TOO
LARGE AND- PEOPLE CONSUMERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DESERVE
THAT MONEY BACK. BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT MONEY SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON THOSE UNSERVED AREAS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHERE
CONSUMERS NOW HAVE LITTLE TO NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR RECYCLING OTHER
THAN POTENTIALLY TAKING IT BACK
INTO OUR STORES. WHICH WE
BELIEVE IS POLICY THAT NEEDS TO
BE RECONSIDERED- IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THOSE SITES- WILL ONLY
HAPPEN WITH CHANGES IN POLICY
LIKE MR MEDINA SPOKE ABOUT THEIR
NEEDS TO BE GREATER FLEXIBILITY
WE NEED TO TAKE INTO THE
OPERATING. A CIRCUMSTANCES OF
THOSE SITES AND WHAT IT ACTUALLY
MEANS TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN THAT
BUSINESS VENTURE THESE DAYS. AND
SO WE LIKE TO SEE A CONSIDERABLE
PORTION OF THIS BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FOCUSED IN THOSE AREAS
AND THEY GIVE REGION'S THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THE CHOICES.
HOW WHAT IS BEST SUITED FOR
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS THOSE
COMMUNITIES THOSE COUNTIES NOT
JUST CREATE SILOS OF A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR RBM TO
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR BAG
DROP. WE NEED TO BE. COGNIZANT
OF THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITIES
WE NEED ALLOW THE TECHNOLOGY TO
GO THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT WILL
ACTUALLY INCREASE OUR RECYCLING
RATES. LET'S NOT LOSE THE FACT
THAT WE'RE STILL SINCE 70%
RECYCLING RATE HOW NOT
WITHSTANDING EVERYTHING WE'VE
GONE THROUGH. SO WE KNOW THAT IF
WE JUST START TO FOCUS ON THOSE
AREAS THAT ARE UNSERVED WE CAN
QUICKLY GET THAT RECYCLING RATE
UP. AND WILL SEE MAJOR BENEFITS
IN OUR PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR READ
ADDRESS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. IN SUPPORT OF
CHARICE I BECAUSE B. C. P. IN
PARTICULAR BE BASED ON SOME OF
OUR EXPERIENCE WITH THE PILOT
WORK. AND WE DO THINK THERE'S OF
OVERLAP IN THE POLICIES THEY'RE
SHOWING THEIR BCP WITH YOUR WORK
ON FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR- WE WOULD
SUGGEST TO FRIENDLY MA'AM IS
THAT WE'RE NOT SURE ARE CAPTURED
IN THE B. C. P. ONE IS AS THEY
ARE INVESTING IN THE ARIENS AND
MOBILE- PROGRAMS. THE QUESTION
IS ARE THE LOCAL CORES WHICH ARE
IDENTIFIED IN THE B. C. P. ARE
THEY ABLE TO HELP STAFF THOSE
ACTIVITIES WE DO THINK THERE
WILL NEED TO BE SOME LOCAL CORE
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THOSE
MOBILE PROGRAMS ANY ARIANS AND
SOME OF THE OTHER TECHNOLOGIES
MIGHT BE DEPLOYED- SECONDLY I
GUESS WE WOULD SAY THAT THERE
WILL PROBABLY BE SOME TIME.
BEFORE THESE VARIOUS MOBILE
PROGRAMS ARE SET UP. IN THAT
TIME IT MIGHT MAKE SENSE TO.
INCREASE SOME OF THE FUNDING FOR
LOCAL COURSE D. INCREASED THEIR
BOTTLE AND RECYCLING PROGRAMS.
IN THE INTERVENING TIME TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO OUR
BEST TO COLLECT. WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR THOSE THAT.
ADDITIONAL TECHNOLOGIES TO BE
OUR ON THE GROUND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THAT APPEARS TO
CONCLUDE THE- PUBLIC COMMENTS
FROM THOSE WHO WERE IN THE ROOM
OPERATOR ARE YOU OUT THERE AND
READY FOR US. YES WE ARE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS FROM THE PHONE LINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE WILL OPEN LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE. GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS EMILY PAPPAS ON BEHALF
ENABLE PAPPAS AND ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT MOLTEN
CORES WE WITH BOTH OF COURSE
BELIEVE THAT THE CLEAN RECYCLED
FEEDSTOCK ARE THE BUILDING
BLOCKS OF CITADEL PACKAGING
SOLUTIONS AND WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMITMENT TO INVESTING AND SUCH
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE SO
THANKS TO THEM FOR BRINGING THIS
PROPOSAL FORWARD- IN RECENT
YEARS THE STATE HAS LOST MORE
THAN 50% OF ITS RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE MUST MUST MUCH OF
IT- WITH THE TAKE BACK MECHANISM
IS MOST CONVENIENT FOR
CONSUMERS. THROUGH WHICH
CONTAINERS ARE SUCCESSFULLY
SORTED AND BREAKAGE EXAMINATION
OF GLASS WITH MOSTLY AVOIDED SO
WITH THAT WE SUPPORT BUDGET
INVESTMENTS IN THE EXPANSION OF
CLING COLLECTION PROPHECIES
INCLUDING ONE PROPHECIES THAT
CREATES A NUMBER OF CONSUMER
CONVENIENT TAKE BACK CENTERS
THAT INCREASE SUPPLY AND REDUCE
BREAKAGE AND CONTAMINATION. TO
EFFORTS TO INCENTIVIZE OR COMPEL
MORE RESPONSIBLE SORTING THAT
RESULT IN CLEAN SHEETS STOCK AND
THREE EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
COMPENSATE FOR THE HIGH COST OF
GLASS REMANUFACTURING STORE HOPE
IS INVESTMENTS LIKE THOSE ABOVE
THEY WILL INCREASE THE RECYCLE
GLASS SUPPLY THAT WILL BENEFIT
ALL BEVERAGE MANUFACTURERS AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT SECURING THE
RECYCLE GLASS SUPPLY NEEDED FOR
BEER AND OUR CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE ON
OUR MUTUAL SUSTAINABLE PACKAGING
BALLS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. LINE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IF YOU HAVE YOUR LINE YOU
DIDN'T LINE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW. HI
MY NAME IS NATALIE AND I'M
CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL OF FIRST
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE WATER BOARD I-
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING I WHILE
IT MAY FEEL PREMATURE BASED ON
OUR EXPERIENCE ON THE GROUND AND
YOU GAVE THE BELIEVE MANY PARK
WILL ULTIMATELY FAIL EVERYTHING
WILL BE PUT ON PROBATION WE
FORTY THINK WATER WITH. FOR
ACTIVE WITH A PAIR FOR THE NEXT
PHASE OF THAT MONTH ON OCCASION
ARE RELATED TO THE VOTE ONLY
ISSUED THREE ON THE REGISTRATION
REPORTING AND CREDIT EXCHANGE
AND THE OF THE- WE WANT TO
ELEVATE THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE
RAISED BEFORE WITH VERY BIO GAS
AS A DIRTY ENERGY WITH LOCALIZED
POLLUTION IMPACT AND- WE HOUSE
PRETTY VALUES AND MISSION
REDUCTION. I'M WITH THE COUNTY
TO THE LTFS AND LAST RELEASED
ITS FORTY FIVE WE'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE EMPHASIZE ANY AND ALL
DIRECTED TO THE PARTY CAN
SERVING AMONG ARE BY LOOKING AT
LEAST THE PERCENT OF. IS RUNNING
BENEFIT FROM GOING BACK AT LEAST
TWENTY FIVE MILLION OF THE ARE
BONTA MANAGEMENT OF THREE THAT
WOULD BE TO AFTER AND- BY THE
COMMUNITY RUN EIGHT AM LAST
REPORT TO ENSURE GAMES RUN AT
LEADER AND THE AND THOUGHT THE
MANAGEMENT OF OUR AT PROJECT
THE- WITHOUT. AT LEAST MILLION
FOR ASSISTANCE IN PROJECT
MANAGEMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. AND WE WILL GO WITH- WE WILL
GO TO HIGH NUMBER EIGHT. MY NECK
YOUR LINE DON'T. THANK YOU AS A
WE ON BEHALF OF THE NEED
CONSERVE K. OUT AND TROUT IN
THE- BEGAN ITEM THE THIRTY- THIS
IS THAT AND FISHING GAME PRESENT
FIND- IN WEIRD SUPPORTIVE OF THE
FOR THROUGH IMPORTANT EXTEND THE
THAT THE DEATH IN AN THIS YEAR-
WE WOULD LIKE YOUR A SHORTER WE
ARE. PERIOD THAT WE CAN WE WITH
THE TO MAKE THE PROGRAM WORK
GOING FORWARD- AND HOPEFULLY GET
AT A HIGHER IN INCREASE IN THE
PERCENTAGE OF REPORT CARDS THAT
ARE BEING RETURNED THANK YOU CAN
MATCH YOUR TIME. WELCOME AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING TIFFANY BAN ON
BEHALF OF BALL CORPORATION BALL
IS SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION COMMITMENT TO
INVESTING IN RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE INTO CREEK-
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE
MATERIAL SORTING PROCESS WE
SUPPORT BUDGET INVESTMENT IN THE
EXPANSION OF CLEAN COLLECTION
PROPERTIES INCLUDING PROPERTIES
THAT INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
CONSUMER CONVENIENCE TAKE BACK
BENCHERS THAT INCREASE THE PIE
DETOX. AND ALSO EFFORT TO
INCENTIVIZE AND COMPEL MORE
RESPONSIBLE THIRTY THAT RESULT
IN CLEAN FEEDSTOCK THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION OF THESE FACTORS
WHEN WEIGHING CHANGES AND
pCONTAINER RECYCLING PLANT. LINE. TWENTY SEVEN. THE ORNING CARE
BLOOMING MEMBERS THE CONTRACTS
ON BEHALF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
WITH REGARD TO ISSUE TO IN
TODAY'S AGENDA WE SUPPORT THE
SEVEN POSITION THE STATE WATER
BOARD FOR SEGMENTATION AND WE
ALSO WANT TO AGAIN HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED FOR TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR EXPENDITURE TO ESTABLISH
A MUCH NEEDED DROUGHT SECTION
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD WITH MUCH OF THE
STATE FACING SEVERE DROUGHT TIME
IS OF THE ESSENCE TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR ALL ACTIVITIES
RELATED SEGMENT IMPORTATION IN
DROUGHT RESPONSE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THESE
ITEMS. THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU CHAPLAIN ON FROM
THE CONTAINER RECYCLING
INSTITUTE WE'RE DELIGHTED TO SEE
THE CONVERSATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE TURN TOWARD BOTH
PROPOSALS IN ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF
HIS BELLICOSITY THE FUNDING FOR
REAL PROGRAM MODERNIZATION HERE
I IS NOT IN SUPPORT OF THE PCP
FOR THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAM HATCHERY. THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
CALIFORNIANS BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAM. THE WORLD
CLASS PROGRAM. AND SPENDING
UNDER MAGNITUDE REQUIRED A COPY
AND OF THE PROBLEM STRATEGICAL
SETTING ESTABLISHED METRICS I'M
DEVELOPMENT MONITORING AND
REPORTING ON METRICS. ARE LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE HAS
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
MODERNIZATION REFORMULATING THE
PROGRAM WITH AN AIM TOWARD
EQUITY FOR CONSUMERS FRAUD
PREVENTION AND DETECTION
ALIGNMENT OF PROGRAM INCENTIVES
WITH PROGRAM OUTCOMES.
IMPROVEMENT OF MONITORING AND
ENFORCEMENT AND MODERNIZATION OF
THE PHYSICAL AND ELECTRONIC
OPERATION OF THE PROGRAM THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. BLIND. TWENTY
NINE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CALL
THE ERA ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION AND
THIS IS ON ITEM NUMBER THREE- ON
YOUR OPEN ITEMS LIST THE OIL AND
GAS AND FORTUNATELY COMMUNITY
PROTECTION PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD
BY CAR- WE STRONGLY BELIEVE-
AGREE WITH THE L. A. O.'S
COMMENTS AND THEIR QUESTIONS- WE
BELIEVE THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
ALREADY DO THIS THE- THE
DUPLICATION OF EFFORT- AND ALSO
WELL. AGREE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA WIRY WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
PUNITIVE. SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE OPPOSE THANK YOU. AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO MORE PUBLIC
COMMENTS IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR HELP THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF YOUR PUBLIC COMMENTS WE
STAND ADJOURNED UNTIL OUR NEXT
MEETING WHICH WILL BE. NEXT WEEK
NEXT WEDNESDAY SAME TIME
HOPEFULLY WITH LESS NOISE
OUTSIDE.
BUDGET SUB THREE IS ADJOURNED.